[Music]
all right
what's going on around talk to me what
is going
on next what's up your favorite part of
sunday that's love that's love
no bad celery in a building holding it
down
lord moderator himself you know what i'm
saying park so what's going on
picking fusion my man daniel mcfix was
in there early i see you christopher
heart you're gonna debate
because you already started we watching
you
now just joking what's that man get to
see arcade oh
okay 42 47 what's going on let me know
if my levels is good
death mobile what's up i see oh my man
hustling motivated here early dmv crap
what's going on mine for hire new name i
like that i like that
what's going on six slab with the earbud
in the other ear you working you working
are you
chilling oh kid i like that man y'all
yeah we're gonna be getting the realm in
here soon i'm up early gotta
make sure addict's not in the bushes
check in on a couple of people
see what's going on hustle always
holding me down on the audio thank you
so yeah we gonna get that rocket king
should be pulling up i spoke to him
earlier
new name nicodemo mastro gio
giacomo jacobo p.s 911
already early that actually was a king's
topic that was actually on
addict's topic asante what's going on
daniel thank you for the levels check
i always appreciate it yeah man we're
gonna get this thing going fun show
today we got the legendary mc fixer in
the building
and uh we ain't gonna solve for the rest
of the lords to wake up we had a late
late night but we should be getting
started
so i will see y'all in a few and uh get
ready
oh hold on sick i can't leave you like
that oh brother i didn't know you was
going through that
yo okay okay pain in the ear okay
oh brother i hope everything works out
with you man damn i'm really good be
careful bro
we're praying for you hope everything is
good i
had to shout you out because you
definitely be holding us down and i hope
they figure out everything what's going
on with you bro
so all good all right i'll be back guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
they don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by coastal
switzerland
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start it
regardless back
with messaging people check my vocals
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh i
guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny work to kind of
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swearing away something but
really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
on a lord's day
all right hear ye hear ye
and we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast and
also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 202 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got microsoft
in talks with discord ps3 and vita
storefronts closing
id at xbox live stream and psnow for one
dollar to discuss
so we gonna get right into it why is kid
laughing
i wanna introduce a load whose content i
first came across through ig unlocked
and the kind of funny gaming communities
nowadays one of our most talented and
entertaining content creators
but truly epitomizes the essence of the
grind with his perseverance
and pure passion for the games industry
introducing the creating host of the mc
fixer youtube slash twitch channel
and a host of the my xbox and me podcast
the lord of gears and owner of the
coolest xbox themed logo
in the game live from london
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
my man lord mc fixer how we doing sir
jeez one intro like this that's all i've
been waiting for like
i can go now like mama made it like i'm
done
thank you so much for having me
seriously i appreciate it
i am happy to be here i've been looking
forward to this one for a long long
time so thank you a long overdue man
huge fan of work as we talked to the
pre-show
you know i'm saying i'm so glad you're
here obviously we've been trying to do
this for some time
you know but glad to have you in the
room brother how you been man what you
been playing what's been going on with
you man
what have i been planning playing this
little game called avengers which is
still
broken it's still broken it still
doesn't work just
just right you know but but i'm enjoying
it at the end of the day
it's i've needed a game at the moment
that i can turn my brain off yeah it's
just that game that i can just relax
i don't have to worry about i'm bottom
bashing i'm i am man i'm whoever i want
to be i just finished the cape bishop
dlc
and the whole card deals here did those
two together because they're not they're
not the longest pieces of dlc
so i always do them together so i can
get the full story there
and otherwise i've been good man just
keeping on my grand as per usual as we
all know
and uh trying to grow each channel as
the youtube algorithm tries to bully me
every week
um i'm sure we all know that pain but
yeah i am i'm fantastic and
like i say it's truly i've honestly been
waiting for this one so i'm
very happy to be here super happy to
have you brother
yeah like i said long overdue huge fan
of content obviously
you know we'll get into when you get
into your background and stuff like that
but it's awesome to see and glad that
you are in good health sir that is
definitely that is very important
because we we
definitely saw what was going on so
salute solved within some chats before i
do our intros real quick all right
of course give me a moment we have
rocker corey with the two dollar super
chat what's good iron lords anyone buy
tcl tvs lately
they started with the tc house later
earlier i don't know about i've been
looking at them sony's
i haven't bought a sony tv in probably a
decade
the only time i'm gonna buy one
that's that's that's how much they're
worth
that's the problem that's the problem
she's really
yeah that's the thing yeah and all she
did was just did some botox injections
and then got butt lifted
sup lord stopping through we'll listen
after work thank you brother no doubt
appreciate it did we get anything else
yeah i think we got we got the delivery
oh yeah we got flame with the five
dollars we chat
i think they should change the name to
ps later because jim clown
clown shoes ryan look at the playstation
3 psp and video store and said
[Music]
who got on the fight team godzilla team
kong choose your titan wisely let's
go oh wednesday is the day today
godzilla all day
all right let me let me break it down
for you really very quickly
kong cannot resurrect yourself from the
dead godzilla
yeah so look for kong to uh
walk away from this movie uh pretty much
batted but still alive
look for godzilla to die but he will be
resurrected
look for them to team up to beat mecca
godzilla has never been done before
those two against mechagodzilla
but we're going to see that classic
battle we gonna see that classic fight
i'm gonna watch it every single
day okay for a whole month on hbo maps
feel bad and of course you know we got
the four horsemen the gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table
a couple of time sensitive intros
because we have a guest
my co-host with the colbos my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
heart
of the young wolf my man that was up
crazy late with me lord addict how we
doing sir
doing pretty good uh they can have my
whole intro today
well what were y'all playing oh okay
we'll get into it
destiny shout out to randolph thorne
shout out to
whole crew kaibatsu we were trying to
get ran through um last wish raided it a
little longer than expected so uh
we will get that going to mess it up
who did it we messed up it's awful it's
like it's my fault
we you know you ain't supposed to bring
two newbies you're supposed to drag one
newbie oh no no no
yeah one at a time let me get everybody
real quick
saga my man bx stand up king can't even
beat the
kong can't even beat the empire state
builder what are you going to do
to the king of monsters you're coming
for you king yo
no no no all right listen we i i
feel everything that you're saying right
but script wise if i'm writing the
script
kong khan can't bring himself back from
the dead and we need more kang later on
so kang is going to walk away from the
battle godzilla can literally
resurrect himself yeah i feel like it's
just
yeah he's a god you know anybody who
hasn't seen the other two
like before wednesday catch up we got
godzilla king of the monsters
skull island you got to watch those two
in preparation for this yeah
they did i see none of me to figure out
none of them
[Laughter]
monsters and then when they give us the
good stuff
the most you gotta be back today was
ultraman the big dude punching over a
little grip that's
the most you got out of me with once i
saw that with the the fake builders in
the back i was good i was like back to
gi joe with transformers thank you
all right i feel you okay okay she
wasn't a fan all right anyway
yeah we got uh lord of roughness with
the five pound super chat
yes lord it's glad it's sunday again big
up my fellow uk man
mc fixer let's go let's go let's go
let's go
then we have raiden blade with a five
pound super chat hey iron lord so many
executives don't
don't guest on ps podcast so why would
they on anything else
because we still can shout out to you
we're not an xbox podcast
thank you thank you stop acting like
just because my personality is large
that we xbox
exactly then we have a bag with a two
dollar super chat godzilla will be found
by a ghost
jesus they going in spanish betty smith
two dollar super chat godzilla is the
king
and the story the book of acts we have
godzilla
anyway jesus raiden blade they stopped
they got y'all going in with them
godzilla's the king so godzilla okay
okay we got it we gotta move
on for a second we love y'all we love
y'all but anyway we caught our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives with the single player selfish
experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patron of the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
what's going on y'all what's good what
up spoof
i know yeah i'm in the bushes as you can
see i'm not you know
the unshaven the unshaven shaving i see
the eyes are not cooperating at all this
morning so glass is on from the
beginning so
god bless so um like lord fixer i've
been playing a little game
called uh avengers really finally yeah
because i remember i told you that i'm
sorry i know
it is a good story i love i love the the
characterization of kamala
um so i'm just at the point where you
get to the hulk and um
you know so a lot of stuff in the
beginning has happened already so i'm
liking the story
at the end of the day though now as you
get a little bit further you start
seeing
that you know that sort of loot the
luderman that
you start the you know the the pickups
and stuff and the fact that
like you get gear pickups but they don't
appear physically on you
they're out there underneath your
skin so that's weird so
i'm going to go through the story
because i know that i heard the story is
really great i don't want to do that but
at the end of the day i still just can't
get it out of my mind then
they made the wrong game with these
characters like they just did
that but he's ready to say something
yeah it needed to be two games is the
thing it needed to be
the third this is my whole problem with
this game which is it needs to be a
single player game for its story
yeah you don't worry about any of that
loot system don't even worry about that
let me tell you this great story of
these characters and then
the second half which is all multiplayer
is the loot stuff that's all they needed
to do
but no yeah
that's my beef with destiny
[Music]
the problem is is the type of game they
wanted it's impossible to make it like
that
like the thing is these people
these people are too obsessed with
chasing after the destiny bag but they
don't
do anything that makes destiny destiny
like yeah
did you catch the um heavyweight
championship yes
i did big shout out to the new
heavyweight champion who's been through
so much
yeah uh it was only a matter of time and
uh
you know i thought stipe went in with
the right attitude that he like
like he did last time it's just that he
thought he hurt him
and he really didn't and he is rather
than step back and take a breather for
himself
and he got stretched with a with a check
hook with a check left yeah
for a second his ego got the best of
them to be in the mix
yeah and
anytime that happens you know it's not a
good thing did a lot of things
very different and very intelligently
like he
defended the takedowns uh he was
checking his leg with those legs
uh and he um he varied his he varied his
levels and punches
like normally uh ingano fights at a
three a level up you know
when he jabbed him to the face he
dropped him to the face twice jabbed to
the
chest touched his stomach with a jab
and you heard it when he hit him yeah
when stephen cause this i thought that
right hand was going to knock him out
and when stephen brought his hands down
to guard the stomach the right came
right out of him and it hit him and i
said oh and he survived that i said
though this might be a really good one
yeah
and we got to the second
yeah when he round that shot to the
temple i was like wow he took that like
he took yeah i was shot prize i was
definitely surprised yeah that's a
champion
besides that uh registered yeah just a
little bit of a dishonor because
it's fantastic that's pretty much it no
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the xs gamer the prophet
of xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir we're
doing
fantastic i want to get to this
interview so listen what i've been
playing this week i definitely been
playing destiny
grinding those grandmasters uh shout out
to my
forte hey forte he jumped to the party
yesterday that was my bad i had to go i
had to um
you know the food and stuff like that
yeah um what i've been playing oh i
definitely
uh downloaded prey well i put my disc in
because i just wanted to play it you
know because i have the game okay um
but i'm i'm proud of my son oh what's up
what's up what's up what's up all right
so
he found out that he can earn money by
playing game pass games yes
okay so okay bring on a tear
in game pass games like hard body yes
right so he said daddy i earned ten
dollars
all right so um i said okay so um you're
gonna go you pick up that destiny dlc
you've been bothering me about right and
i just walked away
and um i'm in the bathroom doing my
business god bless
i'm looking at my phone i'm looking at
my emails
and it says you know little king
uh has purchased vc bucks
for fortnite
he said i love fortnite daddy and this
is what i wanted
salute to gay passive microsoft reward
points for playing
yeah you know what uh it's it's a lot
it's a lot of things with
this uh highly play how you engage yes
and for my son to say okay
he's getting rewarded yes for playing
games
that he would normally play anyway but
incentivized to do
certain things in the reward system and
he
sees that immediate return right in his
investment it's it's insane to watch him
do it and to calculate that stuff in his
head
he's only 10 years old no bro it's
really well done i'm glad you said that
because i
fix it you were jumping i see well i was
gonna say the other thing of that is
learning the value of money as well yeah
which that's something that my dad
ingrained in me from such a young age
like if you want something no problem
but you have to work hard to go get it
yeah
your son has clearly learned that like
look i can game the game of
i'll play games i'll earn money and i'll
buy what i want then i'll convince my
dad to buy me the other stuff
which is amazing shout out to them
because like i'm glad you brought it up
king because
it incentivizes me they have little
things that like on the week
how many games you log then sometimes
they don't feature a game all you got to
do is throw a touchdown and mad and
you'll get another
100 points and i'm like i might just
drop it back
remember when i was playing madden for
no reason yes yes
and i was like oh i got money for that
oh my god
as soon as you turn as soon as you hit
start on the game you see
you see the publications yeah it says oh
yeah turn this in now
you got points facts anything else sir
that's what you did moroccan no
that was it i wanted to get in some
raids and some stuff like that
but um no uh the 20 games that they
dropped inside game pass that was me
going down memory lane and checking this
um frame rate boost
no doubt and i think they sk they
do this very intelligently they
introduce something new to older games
to make you go back to these older games
to resurrect them
and then you fall in love with them all
over again and then
you're looking forward for the next one
and then there's some things i heard in
the background
as to why certain games are not there oh
yeah yeah all right we will get into it
super
i don't know if i read this one from
raiden blade two pound super chat
godzilla's the king so godzilla
yeah um then we have ever born saga five
dollar super chat and before i forget
just wanted to remind everyone that the
ever born kickstarter ends
up tomorrow oh get in there y'all get in
there y'all
for sure and everborn saga once again
five dollar super chat i feel like if
the avengers just focused on story it
would have sold 30 million
every every so-called destiny killer
ends up in the bushes yeah
any game that comes out with a moniker
slash killer
killer and i like how outright is just
doing it the day and they basically
yeah the story feels like a movie script
mm-hmm it does it it's very well done
apart from the fact that it doesn't feel
like you have as much control as you
would if they made a straight-up
third-person action game
yeah um but beyond that that's great
what else we got um
raiden blade five pounds super chat i
know you're not an xbox podcast
but they hide from their fans ps rep
only appears
jet when jack kelly's showing the blow
control
this is true fixer this is far for the
course call for the code
i'm ready i'm ready the realm is spicy
there we go i love it man
then we get paul afc uh five pop super
chat
big up the realm sending the love and
respect paul toss he's praising the
series x
ps fans are gonna be mad yeah shout out
to podcasts we gotta get it back in the
realm we already know and we all caught
up
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realness in
the roman iop not telling what you want
to hear
what you need to hear so um yo last word
with ibontes last night
fire i had my man subledged on great
content creator man please check this
guy out super talented
we had a lot of fun forget about just
talking mario
but i will tell you right now attic
would love it because hibbett addict
already
saves it's not unique gaming
but it's unique to you because you guys
light into zelda and you act like he's
the unique one okay
he has unique tastes but we love him
but i love 64. he resides in the attic
echo chamber
yeah but he he defended his points very
well and i had to respect it
but he said the same thing i'm being
unbelievable
[Laughter]
man we've been talking about that uh out
of worlds murder on or is it every dinos
dlc
really love it oh somebody enjoyed the
room somebody said reggie
reggie mobile nine welcome to the realm
veggies i'll put them crushed in the
chat
that's right man name reggie reggie
nobody's there
yeah we're doing that and then um
obviously still between that and you're
causing it like a dragon still love that
game is wacky hilarious
so good so good so good story as well
and um obviously during the
destiny season of the chosen has been
phenomenal who knows it didn't catch up
with the story please catch up with the
story
this week it was absolutely amazing a
major story paid off with some major
characters
so check that out and shout out to it
for me yeah you already know
shout out to the team last night gaming
forte sinister
you know what i'm saying kai batsu and
of course randolph thor who we had up to
damn they're three in the morning trying
to do last switch raid we apologize
so that was that oh yeah that's why you
didn't want to say
what was what yeah yeah so it's random
and kai
the new guys do it enjoy so we got that
and then i want to do a quick shout out
i never really do this but um
hilltown arab 83. she saw us on twitter
he said can't wait for the show lords
would love if you could give a shout out
to my auntie lena who sadly passed away
the day before her birthday so i want to
give a recipe shout out to him
loyal follower of the realm salute to
you and again my condolences to the
family
so i was given a super chat and then we
got to get mcfix in because he is on
limited time
we have brian eye 10 super chat king
does anyone know when the pony overlord
christopher hart is going to support one
of the many podcasts that he loves to
troll with his blind bs
anyone bueller bueller viewers i i mean
christopher hart christopher harden
super chatted so he christian
first of all i think christopher hall is
a member i honestly think so i thought
he was
um but christopher hart supports a lot
more than a lot of people he's here
every week he defends his position
he's a good guy he's not disrespectful
unless he feels disrespected
i mean i i really i really love the guy
you know and he jumped in when i was
playing on playstation so he's a real
dude 100
so fast i
he was talking about he was in the um
the live stream with us for the i id at
xbox
salute sonic x man thank you for joining
around brother thank you so much
crest in the chest and then our brother
went away dragons tv dude
good afternoon lords no doubt my brother
yo my bad went away i got to get back to
you on what you asked me my [ __ ] i
forgot my bad
then we have dan lazaro dollar super
chat look kong is harry
godzilla uses the fire breath and kong
goes up like mj in that pepsi commercial
then we got r r a r d r d
two dollar super chat two canadian
dollars chris gotta save his money for
seventy dollars sony savage this is okay
it's true
we're putting a pause on put the paws on
it solve it get can you do what you're
gonna do or you wanna do that after what
you wanna do
uh let's let's get more people here
first okay cool
no doubt let's get into it roll so
now that we've gotten to our uh two-hour
intro and got all the
everything we got well 30 minutes this
is this
that was the scariest part about coming
on this podcast i was like yo
it's gonna be a three and a half hour
podcast my girl was gonna beat me
sunday night chilling i meant to be on
the bed watching avengers night oh
man i'm gonna get whacked up don't worry
about time we'll make it work
don't worry about it
we got to focus on lord fixer his video
game system history
was journey as a content creator and of
course what led him to creating the
amazing mc fixer youtube channel so lord
fixer let's start from the very
beginning what were some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
so my first video game system ever was a
sega mega drive
that was that was the very very start my
uh my dad worked at a place called
dixon's which is no longer a thing
anymore um kind of like a
uh what would it be for you guys a um a
walmart
something along those lines um but they
do like they got the electronic
department and that's where my dad
worked so he was always in the game
section so i was always running around
that section like can i have this can i
have that
my dad's like no we're poor shut up
get out of the way um but i remember i
did get the i got a mega drive at one
point
and that was sega mega drive golden axe
um streets of rage i had this one
cartridge we had like all three had
streaks of rage
bejeweled and shinobi on it oh
one cartridge wow that was like the one
that was the game
that was the one or was it was it it
might not have been but the columns
maybe
columns i had that same cartridge
so i was thinking maybe because you know
in the uk that it was bejeweled or
yeah anything i'm gonna say that you
think is a uk ism it isn't i'm thick
i'm very dumb trust me um but yeah so i
started on the sega mega drive then my
dad actually my dad owns like a
mom-and-grop
pop shop sort of thing that he's been
doing for like 20 years now i used to
work there being a kid
but my dad is the go ask go man let me
tell you because
what he would do is i'd have a ps2 and
then a customer come in and be like have
you got any ps2s in stock
and my dad would be like yeah of course
i do come back tomorrow i come home my
ps2 is gone
oh oh no oh no no no no no
you're missing you're missing this yeah
so this didn't happen once
this happened throughout my entire life
oh my goodness
up to 18 years old so let me so let me
break it down for you so
this down what's your history with a
console i've had
everything so you name it i've probably
owned it i may have only owned it for a
week and replaced it to the one i wanted
but i have owned everything
are you implying that these
consoles that you had had to be brought
back for a reason
so let me tell so look i remember i
remember this day like it was yesterday
yo i'm putting an alarm on you allow me
bro
yeah so i remember getting my ps1 for
christmas yeah
i remember unboxing it didn't have no
games had a demo disc i used to rinse
that demo disc
every day i was playing abe's odyssey on
it destruction derby
um what else was on there a few other
games a few other games and then like i
say my dad would just be like yo we
gotta sell it
a customer wants it it's gotta be sold
out here so but then i would come home
and then something else would be in its
place oh it was mainly during the xbox
360 era
of consoles is where this was prevalent
but my dad my dad's not a gamer like us
my dad's just a very very very talented
businessman
very talented salesman doesn't know
anything about games who knows why he
got into games he says
for me and my brother because we were
going to take over the shop working with
family's heart
let me tell um so i remember with the
360
all the time i come home and be like
where's my hard drive because
oh i sold you remember the 360
the silver one yes my dad didn't know
that he's an idiot i love him he's an
idiot he used to sell the damn hard
drive it took me years to explain to him
don't sell the if you're going to sell
my console i'm still annoyed
one time i come home and there was a ps3
with metal gear solid and like i don't
i'm with whoever the playstation hater
is at this time
but at that time i'm like where's my 360
with revolution soccer six
oh no i got your metal gear solid
i don't care about metal gear solid at
that time at that time so i have this
really weird history with games where
i've played so much like if you name a
game i've probably played it not to
completion though
because i only had it for a damn right
so like
i gotta ask you this though because this
is the most wildest thing i've ever
heard it does
it's the best so so so you need to tell
me like you would play a game get
emotionally invested
save date and all that and then you come
home your system's gone something else
is in its place
dude i remember it
so so so fix it wait a minute but your
dad would he did he would take these
systems and then
repackage them as new and so no no no no
no no no no no no no
he would say they were used they would
say they were obviously
you remember consoles would people just
people come in and just like
yo have you got this right right you
would just be like yeah i've got that
doesn't matter what it is
my dad would then go and like i remember
i've got so many stories here that's
what i'm saying to you
don't worry about time we'll make it
work honestly like i remember we went we
went to a shop called woolworths
i bought ten copies of san andreas from
woolworths
then we took him to the shop the game
shop he shop and sold them for 10 pound
more
so he's just a hustler he he like i'm
flipping it and
my guy my guy is the owner hustler
my dad is a businessman let me tell you
everything i know about business i like
it good
the good and the best and the bad let me
tell you
but yeah so my history's super messed up
but where uh so i grew up with
everything
um got very heavily involved in the xbox
360 era
um like most people that was my first
console i ever connected online
we didn't get in there too till later on
in my life because
my mom just couldn't afford it at the
time but i remember plugging in that
ethernet cable
to my free and playing gears of war
it was game over so my internet was so
bad that everybody else used to lag out
of the game and they used to better run
around and chainsaw everyone's still
getting it
absolutely
[Laughter]
and then you realize oh man i've not
been this nice this whole time
gears 2 was a real a real shook for me
i'll be honest with you i turned up and
was like yo
i'm about to destroy these fools it was
like nope
hosted hey mc fixer you're not host
today
me and kids move we would play uh halo 5
and this is like years like years and
years after it came out
well what kind of what kind of days is
it game past day or is it or is it the
sweat halo 5 day
then like 30 seconds it was okay so this
is what kind of day it is
it was real back then man salute so so
at least we had
the 360 for an extended let me let me
let me ask you a question
please all right all right because that
was amazing that was amazing
that was that was literally amazing
because you did not know
if you came in if your progress was
going to still be there right
we worrying about corrupting data and
you worry about that
[Laughter]
somebody else walking out of the shop
with a console
where's my hard drive so okay
all right so what at what age
were you when you didn't have to worry
about the imaginary timer
yeah when he was out of control when he
was out of the house yes like
yeah but you know when you move down
real estate which one was
yours yours yeah you might i remember
psp so psp was actually the first
contract
you think you got jokes like he didn't
sell my psp as well
no no he got the psp too
boys i can't this is a seven hour
podcast
you gotta give me this one you gotta
give us this no because
i don't remember like one specific
moment like he remembered to take the
memory card out
right so that's okay and he didn't so he
never sold my games like very rarely
come home and games were just gone like
the ps2 memory cards were removed that
was fine
but the question was the psp right the
psp was mine i remember i worked at
clarks which is a shoe shop
my godmother was the manager of my mum
work there my artworks there
i worked out in the back for all summer
long to buy my psp
and that was like my first mo i remember
this is this is mad so i remember
drawing a picture
of the psp and taking it downstairs to
my mom and be like
mom i really want this like can we have
it and my mom was just like yo
we can't afford it like straight up like
my mom and dad split up so they weren't
ever together
and so my mom's single parent working
her bath to put food on table and me i'm
like yo
i want converse and i want all these
games my mom's like shut up fool i'm
putting food on the table
and you're getting to school like that's
that's enough and like when you're a kid
you're not understanding
that quite quite the same way so i
remember her being like if you want this
you've got to work hard
and i'm like all right cool so i saved
every single penny that i earned over
that summer
it got held in the safe at clarks so i
couldn't get hold of it at all
i remember going over to game station at
the time and being like yep
walton boom everything thinking i was
the boss so that was my first console
of like real real i bought this and then
i didn't get anything until really the
xbox one
which was like the first time i bought
an xbox again i've been around gaming my
entire life right
i didn't even i didn't have it till
later i wasn't a part of internet
culture
or anything like that didn't even know
what he uh not e3 sorry yeah he fred
didn't know what e3 was
wow like the first the first few phrases
i didn't know what that was like i
remember
when xbox did their showcase and i
thought because unlocked i found what
unlocked was and i was like
oh my god this is a world of people that
are like-minded like me
and just experience all of this fandom
around
things that we love like between between
my dad's shop it was just people that
were coming in that who i was serving
and they weren't really like looking to
chat or anything they're in there
they're getting their stuff and going
my brother who was a footballer so he
wanted to play soccer player
um so he wanted to that was his realm
and i was always the gaming kid that was
what i did i lived in brazil
you didn't have like a best mate that
you would go over and play games at his
house or vice versa
a few i lived on a council estate which
is like the projects for you guys so we
had a few of those but again right
grammy eyes kids they're always trying
to jack their stuff my pokemon cards got
stolen
so i was just more of a guy like i'm
gonna stay in the house
we'll go play football every now and
then but i was indoors no you can't
borrow my stuff
no i'm not going to do myself my dad
will come home and stop your stuff if
you do that
that's a good that's a good reason too
yeah okay there was a few people
just just start borrowing your friends
psps
xbox one i remember me and my fiance who
i've been with for 10 years now
she she's kind of been i've always i've
been a musician i've been doing content
creation now for a lot of years
so i've always been broke it's the
honest truth of it yeah
so my girl was always the one that had
like a stable job she put herself
through university like she's the smart
one out of us too
and i remember xbox one she was like do
you want it and i was like yeah
and like she gave it to me it was like a
moment for me of like
nobody can take this fast this vcr
player
this big ass vcr nobody can take this
from me this is
mine
a lot of issues with that when i was
growing up so uh my dad was taking it
for other reasons
yeah yeah i can hear that i hear that
trust you yeah i remember i would never
forget like
he took the ps2 i had a ps2 and i had
like almost
i spent years collecting all these final
fantasy games
and i came home all the games were gone
oh man the ps2 was a ps1
wow the ps1 had a ps2 controller
yep yeah yep been there brother i
promise you i understand and relate
yeah that's all hurt me see that's
that's the part i wanted to get to
i wanted to get to that emotional part
where
you felt that this is it yeah
this is not going anywhere no way yeah
and and for it to be your fiance your
wife
your girlfriend for it to be that
individual to make that
significant impact like that you know 10
years in and you look back at that
moment like
you know she brought me this and this
was this was
she didn't even know probably you know
what it was
until then but it really meant a lot
yeah that was the part i wanted to get
to because
not knowing when you i couldn't i
couldn't even imagine that
i really honestly couldn't even imagine
that but
now you felt secure and safe in this in
this space
in your gaming space yeah man well i
lived at home for a long long time we
even moved back home now
like i move on to save for a hat because
i live in london again
everyone knows notoriously london is
ridiculously priced
yeah um so we're just back home saving
again i'm like look
i can work from anywhere my missus is a
teacher i can work from a bedroom it
don't matter to me my
my home is where i make it happen don't
matter what space i got i'm making a
game in space exactly exactly
so for me yeah that moment was she she
knows as well anyway because i told her
how to play she's a game she's
she's not a gamer but she games for me
like we game together because of like
beautiful i taught her how to play left
for dead that was like the first game
ever told
it's the easiest game of like saved my
life we're running through these zombies
yeah i told her that i taught her fifa
and then yeah we just bonded man like
honestly
you could interview me just about her
because she's she's my queen man
honestly
creation that perfect transition because
um you know
obviously your journey is amazing the
grind the perseverance
everything you've been through is is
crazy just for you to still have that
positive mentality and still keep going
so how did you now translate that and
say okay
i want to make i love gaming but i now
want to be a content creator i want to
create a chat like what was that
transition for you so like i said i was
a musician beforehand
so mc fixar comes from rapping that's
what
i was a rapper um so
so for me it was a case of my i was part
of a rap group called a g
flyer which was like around our little
area we thought it was a big deal
we were doing was doing these festivals
we're getting paid to do shows we're
getting
recognized in our local mcdonald's like
people asking for oil grass we thought
we'd made it like that was my version of
like
bro i'm gonna live off this what this
hundred pound show that i'm sharing
between six of us
that's that's obviously how i was living
but um yeah that they
we split up as all groups do some people
got some egos unfortunately not me
because i wasn't the talented one
i've always been the smart one when it
comes to content in terms of like
how to how to market things i was the
treasurer and
all the businessy stuff of the group
yeah and um eventually i was like i'm
looking for another creative outlet and
i was watching i was watching ign
religiously at the time
religiously like every single day and
greg miller who's
one of the people i look up to the most
he knows that um he just
he just used to say it all the time
which was um like he said
just do it just do it just do it you
used to say it all the time just like
just start just start you'll start the
process and we'll get there you get when
you get there
and one time i just remember saying to
myself bro like
no no disrespect to anyone i was
watching at the time it's like but i can
talk
about video games in my own way which is
most important to me
and that's why i love this podcast so
much when i'm listening because you guys
you guys are you it doesn't matter
what's going on you guys are you guys
and you have your uniqueness and you've
got obviously the amazing audience that
you have
which they all they all come for you
right and that was always my feeling
with virgin i felt like
at the time not just ign but at the time
of very robotic
very yes people no one was asking the
questions i wanted them to i was like
you know what i'm going to start doing
it myself so i remember i started with a
piece of blue tuck
and an ipod touch as not i know some of
the if you're a young kid out there in
this chat which is probably not as young
maybe the fortnite son he'll
but but i remember i just stuck it on
the wall i was like that's my tripod
and here we go
[Laughter]
there was an evolved video i was found
evolve evolve let's play and the camera
fell off the wall
i just left it in the end it was like
this is me i was like one of the only
people cabin for that game
that's like one of the very few games
no i won i was playing it so
i probably still have it installed um
they they took me i guess i'm referring
to like uh
like anchorman in them okay because i
remember we we all played it but like
like man i was always like i would say
man involves good be like
man you need to start playing good games
i thought it was going to be a thing no
no
you grinded getting to start going on
the channel it comes back to like i
always say like people always assume
that like you just get things and it
happens overnight like
even looking at king's room king's room
didn't start like that no it built up to
that
like and people people don't get that
even with me today it's like oh you've
got a nice camera you've got this and
you've got that
oh your parents are rich i'm like i come
from the bottom of the bottle bridge
like literally it's not it's not like
don't get me wrong we got by i'm not
acting like i'm the brokest guy anymore
but um it was just for me i just i was
just building the building to build
every christmas was a new
content creation tool gift it was lights
and then it was a green screen and then
it was a capture card and then it was a
for i've been doing this now like nearly
six years
um my i did my xbox to me which is my
weekly xbox podcast and that's the sort
of the broadway i've know how long i've
been doing it
288 weeks never missed a week
that's how long i know i've been doing
that so we've been doing that too
sometimes i'll be seeing like
because i i i'm a regular podcast
listener and when people cancel their
podcast for the week yeah
i'm like man now what i'm going to do at
work today and then
and then i'll be thinking how many times
do i say that
and i hope he never misses never mind
like the only time we miss is when we
ain't here to do it they do it oh it's a
show
or is it no no no you know what i don't
like yeah they
want to go on holiday right one holiday
when they go on holiday and it's usually
like a week or two yeah
that's sunday i wake up with the
it's like a dark cloud and i'm like man
and i'm gonna do this it's
not today
come to me from that one yeah listen
listen to me
we don't take holidays
makes an executive decision to say oh
well you know what week
you know like really really clear very
quickly for context
you're doing a million things yeah you
know at that time you know god bless the
dead
our brother dizzy was in and out on
certain things and you're doing the
website
he's doing hosting he's putting together
this he's doing a friday show
so now when i do uh you know dcx out on
on friday nights and doing kos i
understand
so he needed to break but i i i get it
brother definitely
but when they when we off i'm on with
you
[Laughter]
but yeah man so i just sort of i grew
grew grew from that
bolstered myself in when a lot of my
successes come from the kind of funny
community yes that is
i i help run the uk side of their
stuff so i do if we do a meet-up i'm the
one that does all the meet-up stuff
when the when the guys come over from um
america they came over and we did like a
nando's me up
which getting nando's is no small feat
and we did it at the o2 if you know what
they're going through
yeah yeah that's cute what's your love
your luck pure luck let me tell you
completely one thing i can always uh
give greg miller that i've seen over the
years is
he got no problem putting other people
on his platform he got no problem giving
people
chances and yep absolutely literally
could do we did we did the uh we did a
nando's meet up which
it just so happened that the person who
was meant to be performing there
could didn't cancel their show so i went
to the managers like hey i'm going to
bring 300 people here with a celebrity
can we have the whole of the downstairs
of the nando's yo
didn't know that french people were
actually going to turn up but 300 people
actually turn up fire so we packed out
the whole of that
obviously this is just community stuff
this is just community stuff right
spoke to greg got him to do like he's
his movement i'm i'm somebody
though i want everybody else to always
have their moment right yeah
i was it was rtx london and i already
had an interview booked with greg so i
wasn't really
i went there like oh my god greg this me
for the first time like that wasn't that
wasn't my mo my ammo was very much
let every single other person have their
moment
and try and facilitate that to the best
of my ability so we had greg there we
had tim gettys there and we had andy
cortez there
cameron cough turn up it was just it was
just a cocktail of amazingness and like
it's one of my favorite moments so but
that really helped i've done stuff
before that but that
moment really bolstered me in the
community yes um of doing things
and ever since then i've just been going
like creating content weekly on my podca
on my show doing the podcast
doing the mc fixer channel and then
doing twitch which i turn into a
full-time thing which is the hardest
thing ever
do not go full time in this stuff if
you're not prepared for it
you know what sucks mc iop finally
started getting a little bit of uh you
know popularity
and then the world shuts down you can't
go you can't go to any events
can't go anywhere you had to just
transition
and pivot you know and plan later and
he'll work on other things but
uh like when you you was talking about
being selfless
right you wasn't being selfish you were
being selfless
and you were trying to facilitate
everybody's position let them do them
let them
shine in their best glow and the rewards
will fall on you later
like you wasn't looking for them that's
my anytime i do
anything for anybody i'm not on here to
brag about what i do that's not what
it's
about for me it's just explaining the
scenario right never do
anything for anybody because i do stuff
for a lot of other people it's not just
kind of funny but it's never for the
fact of like oh now i get this in return
right never that it's never ever
there's too many people it's just about
to say there's too many people out there
that they do it for the wrong intentions
not for the love of the people
it's not for the love of the community
it's like if i do this then this is
going to happen and you'll get bolstered
to hear
i'm not interested in either if i never
go on if i've never gone kind of funny
i'm gonna be heartbroken
because that's a goal of mine but i'm
not owed it
right it's not something i am owed and
that's something that that i always try
to explain to people like
i do these community meetups not to be
like oh i'm mcfix so let's make it
happen
it's to to to just love it i love doing
this
it's so much fun but yeah i want to
transition because um
yeah yeah okay i get out of concern you
remind me a lot of our friend eric's
gaming
like the same mentality like he's just
like look like at the end of the day
what's the point of having the
popularity in the wealth when all your
friends broke
down yeah no doubt i want fox yeah i
want to transition because um
you basically first of all that event oh
to that that's fire that that
was not that was bad i wanted you
because one of the coolest things i've
seen
on your channel that i thought was
really
touching really emotional to me was what
the community
did for you and and it was a
kind of a kind of funny community moment
you know pretty cool christmas surprise
right yeah and um can you tell us
like how that whole thing went down and
why that meant so much to you i'll give
you i'll give you the full of it so what
happened was to give
big shout out to mr moody in my chat
who's always there
guarantees in your chat now guarantee it
absolutely mr moody and a guy called dan
only again two people have been with me
from a very very start really
and they were like we're going to buy x
we're going to buy a fixer and xbox one
x i couldn't afford it at the time
like it was just a case of and at the
time they weren't really selling it to
me it's like more powerful xbox i was
like
ah it's fine i don't need it i don't
need yeah i want it what does that mean
right i don't need it i don't need it to
help my career move forward that's right
and um they put it together i spoke to
my community
and was like how much can we raise they
raised a bunch of money they needed a
little bit more
so they went to the kind of funny
community and a bunch of people who have
never met me before
never knew who i was any of that put in
to buy my xbox as well
i then find that like all these new
people keep jumping in my twitch chat
and i'm like
what's going on here that's super weird
like who are these people
oh yeah okay cool no problem
they were distracting me at one point
for my girl to run past
to hire the xbox in the house so i
didn't know anything about it i had no
clue wake up christmas morning my girl
was like we should vlog christmas i'm
like hell no
what do you mean i'm vlogging christmas
are you crazy no this is my like
i give the world so much oh moody's in
literally literally so they my girl was
like we should vlog christmas i'm like
hell no i'm not doing that she's like i
really want to i'm like
i'm getting my queen she gets what she
wants it's done we're vlogging christmas
so she's like all right we'll set up a
camera we're opening our presents in
front of it yeah
all right all right we're doing this i'm
not sure what she's doing
what she's doing all this you you didn't
like think that's nothing
no because you've got as a content
creator you're always creating content
you're always creating memories
even when you're not creating content
you're creating like oh this is a great
story for the podcast yeah yeah
that's funny because i watch this dude
and he like builds stuff
and he spent like six months building
something he's like
tomorrow i'll go record it if it breaks
it breaks if it works it works
regardless
that's literally that's literally the
mentality for it so yeah like
we do this we sit down we open my
presents and i'm like all right cool
perfect that's going to be crap content
there's no way that's going out and then
she's like oh one second can you hold my
phone
gives me the phone and video plays and
she's talking to me
and then hold up you can go see the
video over on the my xbox and me channel
if you want to see this video i'm
watching it and then she pops up someone
else pops up thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you
then she gives me a card and i'm like oh
there's a video with a dope
card i've got a card from the community
i'll keep that forever then she hands me
the present
and i'm like i'm still not i'm like i
don't know what the hell is that
registering
like he's not just i'm not thinking
about it like i've had
i've had amazing things happen to me but
nothing to this level i like at the time
it was a
300 450 pound console yeah like
it's a lot of money and i've got other
stories from this as well but like
it it was just one of those moments it
got handed to me i opened it and i'm
just gobsmacked absolutely gobsmacked i
couldn't believe it was happening
and then i just break down in tears i'm
a crier anyway
i love it i love it i love a good cry
i'm not one of these manly man's
like man how dare you like all that
no so i just broke down like it was one
of the most overwhelming things to know
that a bunch of
quote-unquote strangers have come
together
because they like me enough to buy me
this thing
and yeah it was it was an amazing moment
and i've never had anything
i've had to happen again since that and
it hit me again
exactly the same way brother it was it
was that's amazing yeah because i
know what's like she's been the catalyst
for two of them
like though the xbox one where you know
she got you that secure feeling and then
to be behind the scenes helping out
and and to do the video i understand
exactly why you praise her as much as
you do
and and i get it brother i really get it
this is beautiful right here honestly
like
again i'm in a very different scenario
to most people my girl my fiance hey
leah name is haley is the bread winner
of our family
like we she's the one that goes out and
does the quote-unquote rule job
and she lets me stay at home and live
out my dream too and she believes in me
enough every single day
that i'm going to make it that's fire
we've we've all got different levels of
making it
so it's not it's not to always be the
biggest no one sounds good
right 5000 concurrents nothing like that
just to be self-sufficient off of making
content
that's why you launch your patreon
that's why you have a sub button that's
why you do
the shout outs that you guys have been
doing for the amazing audience we we
understand it right you build up to that
and for me i just i have to always shout
out because without her i wouldn't be
where i am right now like
without me there's no mc without her
there's no mcfix officer
i think it's one of those things where
it's the making it part is cool
but just the fact that she knows you
love it yeah and she supports you with
it because that's what my wife is like
i'm just happy to see you happy being
able to talk to your friends every week
and it's like you know you the success
is fantastic and the fact that you guys
are growing is amazing
but every week i know that you're happy
for whatever the
four hours there you know talking to
your boys and
and and that's what it is it takes a
special person to acknowledge that and
not feel like
hey you're taking time away from me yes
because the opposite effect is
yeah it's it's it's a it's it's a hard
line to
to go but when they see the level of joy
because i'm this is all i'm getting i'm
getting absolute joy but i'm seeing
i'm getting security i'm getting joy i'm
getting
love when you talk about it all those
key words pop into my head
because those are fixtures in your life
she's a fixture in your life that brings
you
security joy love surprise so those
things right there
and it's it's amazing it's amazing you
understand
and it's amazing that like you said
you're a crier yes sir
i'm right with you i'm watching black
panther
i cried through the whole movie of black
panther i know people like black panther
why
anyway there's another thing but um the
whole movie like right
all the way through the whole movie and
it's and you got to be able to be
a humble man within yourself and secure
within yourself
[Music]
i cried like a baby at the end the last
of us too
oh no i know and she looked at me like
really i'm like
you don't you don't know ready player
one for me the film
like the whole the whole film i was
almost crying she looked at me like
why i'm like this depicts what we go
through every single day in such a good
way
of like i'm probably friendly showing a
tangent i'm so sorry
very lucky in what i've done again
there's always you've got that goal of
where you want to get to right
mine is very much money orientated just
so i can take that burden
off of her right it's always been the
thing of like i want to be able to be
self-sufficient enough
and every time we're getting a little
bit closer every time you do something
you get a little bit closer you're not
there yet but you get a little bit
closer
now you're the question the different
things happen and you start working with
different brands playing stations yes
bro and i see them sponsorships we're
doing some other bits
literally yesterday like we sat down we
did we did like five invoices together
i've never again i'm learning like
running a business is stressful
yeah like invoicing people is stressful
and i'm sitting there on this influence
like come on
drags me by my head sits me down like
doing this invoice like
stop trying to run away from me let's do
this properly like i say she's
she's a goddess i love her to the queen
so let's get some changes they said that
man loved him
she fixed it right now that's super chip
bro yeah they
let's go with clayton st sire two uh two
dollar super chat these super chats
aren't done rolling in
much love no doubt and we got michael
aka best stocks find this five dollar
super chat
well well well psn is a dollar
hmm he's ridiculous at the tables turned
hmm it's ps broke
[Music]
he's ridiculous in the bush
i know i'm late but in honor of the new
turtles game coming out
i want to ask each member of the realm
who is the best
ninja turtle oh that's a good one i'm
going with donatello again
rafael i i i like mikey but at the end
of the day like
as i got further in it i like you
sagging your jimbo
so no no turtles in that turtle oh wow
do you want the rabbit i want
you said dog yes all right and who did
you say emcee fixer
leonardo
that is very you know when you look at
that whole thing
when you look at it those characters
are us the character that you
picked is the character that is that you
see yourself the most then
yes get it that's cute
nobody nobody said rap nobody said right
now
you said okay yeah i'm the hot head
there you got slobo back slap five
dollars so we chat afternoon gentleman
and addict
damn slow literally a slow-mo backslap
why don't you talk again see if you go
in the bushes for like 190 seconds
don't be moderating using his powers
these are the followers
one of the other reasons avengers didn't
work as a looter is that you don't get
to see your
important deluded gamers yeah we said
that out i don't i don't need a new rib
cage like i don't that i don't know that
didn't work for me
pixel bit g too loud super chat never
heard of this cat but he's interesting
af no doubt now you know about fixing
fix the
then we got raiden blade with two round
super chat mc fixer facts london is
expensive i'm in chief
oh okay yeah yeah yeah salute then we
got easy shock five dollars from chat
after mc's childhood how is he not a
super villain by now
he could have went left that's true
then we got wandering dutch ten pounds
super chat good dog
good good afternoon lords and a great
guest showing some love have a great
show thank you very much
we was on the midweek mix-up v-kick yes
luke put his twitter in there too hustle
yeah he got a hustle guy he's on it for
us mm-hmm uh i think we're good
recording
we all caught up real real quick guys in
the chat i'm i'm seeing the discourse
get a little out of hand
guys you're attacking each other you
could debate go back and forth
just be respectful right like the mods
are doing a great job but
you guys are making them work way too
hard with all the adults here
have you know have debates that's
fantastic
and focus on this amazing guest exactly
you guys are arguing amongst yourself
like it's not listening in the future is
gems being dropped today
now they listening to the picture
they're just in there acting up
[Laughter]
what's up brother out of all this 400
people
and let's hit those that like i'll hit
that like and share that out
but out of those four there's not one of
you guys that didn't
fall out your chair when he said his he
will come home
and he would either have a new console
or he would have a memory card in its
place
i think if that scenario would have been
me i would have been in jail man
you need to tell me i just spent 10
hours on final fantasy tim
you stole the whole concept
his key point was i had
i'd rather have one thing than have
everything for a week at a time
i agree with you to a degree i think it
was the case of
give respect to my dad
just come in he didn't just come in and
go as much as i hated it at the time
he didn't just come in and go look i had
a gamecube at one point like
yeah and i had games i played smash bros
i played mario party i got all of these
experiences
now that i tell when people are like i
see on the podcast and people are
laughing about it and it can
it's good it's good i love it i like it
as much as it was annoying
it was annoying at the time now it's
funny because like obviously we're
talking about the the
the arguments that happened in chat
right yeah people come in my chat and do
the same thing and i go
guys i just love games i just love games
i feel like
i had a curiosity fixture what was what
was that game
that she was in the middle of and you
came home and that console was gone
oh so that's a really great question no
there was you know what the one that
hurt me the most was it was on gamecube
actually and i was getting my ps2 back
and it was i think it was one of the
wrestlemania games
and i was like it was xa i think i think
you're 100
right and i remember playing that i was
halfway through it or something and then
it was just gone and i was like i wanted
it back the ps2 obviously so i could
play resident evil but
yeah you've done me dirty
for another week he's like no you
fixture got to the point probably where
he he didn't have attachments to
anything
i got to that part where i wanted to
know when you felt
safe yeah that was it that was my that
was the biggest thing because
i i don't understand but
you know through my childhood i
purchased all my consoles i didn't have
a parent to purchase
not not one of them and i had every
console
from atari vetrex from atari 2600
uh atari i mean um vetrix
to neo g all the way through i purchased
them all by myself
right so that was the only security i
had with that
you had everything but didn't have that
security so yeah
we diametrically opposed in that area
and i wanted to know when were you able
to feel
secure yeah when i was an old man but
the xbox one came out yeah
[Laughter]
showing love from the sixth grade show
shout out to the six years
then let's put the crest in the chat for
the newest member andy crawley thank you
awesome
put the press up here there let's go
let's go then we have
black ronin five dollar super chat thank
you for the support brother
cause we missed something i gotta shout
him out gamer by choice he brought a bug
he said i can now start by morning with
incredible ilp swag salute lords i see
you got that lord's game
thank you so out of much
because you know lord fixtures across
the pond like i'm curious where the
listeners are from
put the the country that you're from in
that chat i'm curious like our audience
in general
no doubt no doubt and while that is
going on one last thing about
the amazing podcast you have man the my
xbox and me and they also
lady hayley also does some uh stuff with
you too right some content as well
yeah we've so we'll start with my xbox
in me my xbox me is my weekly xbox
podcast
all things xbox we cover i've been doing
it like i said 288 weeks
um it's my it's my stability it's the
thing that
every week i can go there and talk video
games and it's just with a great
audience that we've cultivated
the problem with me is i moved it around
so it was on my channel my main channel
which i've now
sort of separated as just a medium thing
and then i've moved it to the my xbox
the miniature because i wanted to grow
what you guys have
which is it to be a group of people that
own this thing
that can start unfortunately finding
good people is extremely
hard because not everyone i what i've
found anyway in this in this game is
like a lot of people just want to come
on and be on a podcast right
but they don't want to do the articles
they don't want to do the sharing the
content they don't want to do the
actual things that take time and stuff
so yeah we're still grinding you've got
the my xbox and me channel
if you're on a weekly podcast which we
sometimes do live streams
and myself and crash shout out to crash
and we just brought on uh matt p video
as well who's doing some great stuff
for us and then yeah my main channel
which is just mcfix or
youtube.com love the grime brother
you're out here killing it man
it's been phenomenal to see the growth
again i was i know i was on unlocked and
i was so fortunate to see that you
and learn about your journey so it is
cool man it's cool to see
before we get it i gotta ask the
question that we asked all the lords in
the realm
the top five i need that top five all
the lords no leading the witness
i'm not saying nothing because this this
gets very contentious
top five video games or franchises
of all time let's go
we'll go games right yes oh my mix i'm
actually just i don't get showered up
um resident evil 2 is my favorite game
of all time
it is the game that got me into game
instagame that made me understand what
gaming was
on the og resident evil 2 zapping system
and so you open the locker yes and
there's two things there's a machine gun
and there's a backpack
and you don't know it at a time but if
you take both and you do the separate
b a b scenarios you come back to that
exact moment and the things are gone
and that was the moment it clicked in my
head and was like games are special
mm-hmm you can do this games are special
so that one plays a big place in my
heart metal gear
another game that was which was amazing
i've got stories for everything which is
my friends used to come over to my house
to watch me play metal gear sorry too
again they could come in they couldn't
borrow [ __ ]
excuse me you're good you're good
i apologize um yeah so they could they
used to come in but used to bring me
biscuits
and be like here's a biscuit here's a
biscuit can we come watch you play
because again i've grew up broke and my
mom was like you're all ready
to walk but i like how the biscuits is
there to lure him like
so i'm sorry
you already had a twitch follower yes
before twitch was i guess you
paid in cookies
did they ever ask to play or that wasn't
part of the deal you just get to watch
ask me play what
[Laughter]
they always assume that you gotta do
stuff
which again kind of casual i understand
that but football is
is a big hobby of mine and i've played
every single fifa since
90. what team is you i said wait what
team is you first
you know listen i i know uh
europeans are very serious about things
what yeah team or you know
i support tottenham which is going to
hate everyone is going to hate me
i i support wild teams they're awful
they're terrible but don't worry about
that
two more
huge huge huge every single gears of war
going forward i play everything
and uh we even did on my xbox with me
this week they were like what about a
first person horror
gears of war games spin-off title and i
was like yep i'd play it i'd play it all
day long
that and then oh gosh if i had to think
of one more off the top of my head
oh joel i'm gonna say this it probably
isn't in my top five but on my head
right now
sunset overdrive is such a great game
sunset overdrive is such an um
you know you might be the most unique
yeah yeah a lot of first timers i like
the metal gear tool
you know the sunset sunset sunset to me
is such a great game
like it upsets me now that playstation
bought with some of the extra will never
get over on xbox
but in the same breath i hope that it
lives on i hope they truly
truly either reboot it or give us a
number two overall i feel like
i feel like i feel like the odds of them
not rebooting that game for like a jab
at microsoft is so
yeah low like they're they're they're
bringing that game back at some point
yeah you got to respond i hope they
bring it back do
would they i don't think so but i hope
they bring it back because it's one of
those games like my son is playing it so
um i i gauge a game's popularity
by his uh through his eyes yeah right so
i go past and i look in his room and see
what he's playing
and i'm like mm-hmm but he was playing
that and he was really having a good
time so
i could see how it made it there because
it is a good goal
for lord fixer favorite console
of all time oh that's a hard one
again because i've played on everything
yeah let's go we've talked about
everything but i think my most fond
memories with a console is
actually the n64 just because that was
the console that me
my dad my brother all sat down together
and we played mario kart did he come
racing
golden mario party smash bros
like that was the one that brought us
all together and that was like it was so
accessible for my dad doesn't play games
but he would play on the n64
so i have a lovely one we missed that
ever though how did we
get through your game in history right
stories get to that part it was so cool
we got sidetracked with your
with you with your father your brother
and you playing diddy kong racing
i mean i remember i know
you're very everywhere everywhere bro
i'm like an onion i'm late
um my favorite console would probably be
the 360. the xbox 360 was a special
turn plugging it in for the first time
online was
was just magic ghost recon ghost recon
uh the first was the first one i think
that came on the 360 and then gears of
war pro evolution soccer i remember
playing a kid again in brazil
mum i'm playing this kid in brazil this
is crazy like
that those are some special moments and
then that whole
catalogue of games i mean silly games
like playing minecraft for the first
time but this is
this is gonna go nowhere this is awful
and then i'm playing until three o'clock
in the morning building a hat
what am i doing you know what the worst
thing about minecraft is fixture
every time you complete a project you
come up with some other dumb project
that you shouldn't have done
it's like it's like you you build a big
house on the hill in a big house by the
river
let's connect them
[Laughter]
you know what it's like connecting them
is not good enough let's make a toner
under the water that connects them like
that we built a castle i remember one
time building a castle and then being
like
why did we build a castle like just why
did we do this like
it means nothing but yeah yeah so 360
would be mine
remember okay i love the choices man yo
all five brother great gaming history we
gotta get into texas we can talk to you
all damn like we go not gonna get any
job
done i know time is limited but um let
me get uh sorry i'm gonna get finished
i'm super chats just get the poll at
least get
the first topic two more new members to
the realm yeah crushing the chat
for raiden blade thank you my brother
put the crush in the chat
and roscoe truman welcome to the realm
thank you so much
then we have a ten dollar super chat by
roscoe truman not good that microsoft
getting discord for
all of us we'll talk about that in a
little bit and then we have raiden blade
with the two power super jack condemned
by
sega best harry potter oh yeah it could
have been fire
[Music]
that was fire i remember that i want to
make it out
before we go into the topics yeah what's
up uh this monday uh laura king and i
were going to be streaming
it takes two at one p.m it takes two
months uh
so you know what's funny is like
a fixer you got it right me
haley gotta be playing that one bro come
on oh that's what's up um
you know uh we we actually played the
their last game um
way out the way out way out great game i
killed king at the end spoilers
you know i didn't snitch
[Laughter]
[Music]
watch that stream mm-hmm
it was probably the moment king realized
he had to kill me man
like you know what was funny the moment
like our hell's popped up
and he brought out the gun i can
literally hear king
like sit up in here in his chair oh
you're getting it
[Laughter]
it was it was such a moment and it was
probably one of the
fun most well me and attic had some
moments before but this is the first
time
we just you know recorded it and put it
out there
it's absolutely uh mel gibson and danny
glover's song
hilarious salute to y'all buddy cop film
oh
so if you said anything else we good on
the switch i
one more thing so uh last week not last
week for our 200th episode you guys know
that that we gave away a couple of
hundred dollar gift cards
of your friend lord uh lord suarez yes
um and one of them went to bill
stillwell the wall
of bill the great wall of bell facebook
and he graciously wanted to pay that
forward to the rest of the realm so we
are going to re-roll that right now
quickly uh-oh somebody getting a hundred
dollars thank you
lord stillwell for that much time
give me a second man i got i got a rig
the lords are not allowed to participate
let me give my pseudo name
it's your w account
hold on hold on a piece of paper that
i've secretly
entered the realm like 80 times a week
all right and the winner of the hundred
dollar gift
card reroll
[Music]
fake excited rubber
where we going
[Laughter]
you said another underrated game that i
love sleeping dogs yes i remember that
actually actually uh i might drop that
code for that game in the in the chat i
got a code for that game
oh we all could have we gotta move time
time time time let's go come on
all right poll was last week um the
results are in
to the question with the latest square
enix presents event revealing for spoken
as a ps5 console exclusive and outright
is his launch day and date on game pass
which strategy do you prefer heading
into the next generation
the winner of our three-way ilp log net
poll at 75
clear runaway was outriders in game pass
most make gamers subscribe to your
service coming in at second place with
only 17 to vote was the messy laws
it's all fun and game until the switch
locks down my favorite exclusive at 720p
last place at only 6 was forsaken
for spoken exclusivity make gabriel's by
the console
group lord sovereign your thoughts
please lord sophomores
oh man i mean for a game a game like
outriders to be
day and date in game pass
is huge and it's gonna show a lot of
what that game cap
who did that push can do for a game that
is a game that i think
people after the demo some were high in
it some weren't some were still some
were just skeptical of paying so many
dollars for that game
you don't have to yeah now you don't
have to we'll do that for you
you have to though you have to if you're
in the wrong camp
your console got wings and you can rip
it off the sides and show his belly
this big
this is pure facts your wallet has been
saved
if you you know you know what's going to
be the crazy generation
are you going to address him as that
every time you say phil are you going to
say his fool listen
when when i gave him his shirt at e3 it
said dominance in the back right
yup he did and he put it up phil put it
up
and when when they chant his name at
every show we go to they
they chant dominance right i did that
for him
you understand so what he did for me is
he put a game that i was super
lukewarming
and if i was in the other camp jim dance
moves ryan ain't doing nothing for me
right now is he's complicit and he's
making sure
that these dudes can feel the same way i
feel about phil
for him he's getting done with you but
phil has laid the groundwork he did this
time with this philadelphia i will
address him as phil
dominance maximus are really expensive i
can't
moving on let's get to the first topic
finally we got to keep this limited for
fixing he's unlimited oh so anyway look
according to the wall street journal
microsoft is in
exclusive talks to acquire discord
dev dealer is valuing the uh chat app at
10
billion and could be completed next
month just a little uh excerpts they
just say again it's in advanced
talks they said according to people
familiar with the matter and they said
the software jordan
software giants microsoft looks to
deepen its um consumer offerings so yeah
look they said also i said assuming that
the negotiations
don't fall apart but for what we hear
exclusive talks so let's get right into
this y'all
lord fixing like what what are you
feeling when you heard this news come
about
does it interest you does it not
interest you where are you at with
microsoft
possibly acquiring discord well as a
streamer again i've been using discord
for
years upon years upon years before all
these newbies keep jumping right now
oh yeah discord's great isn't it i'm
like yeah we've been doing it
um but yeah for me it's a case of i want
it to happen in one way because i want
to see xbox integrate discord
on the console because i think it will
be very beneficial
for live chat the the sound quality on
discord is way better than xbox live
chat
i don't use like xbox live chat at all
so if i play an xbox live chat with you
i actually like you as a person
otherwise go straight up otherwise i'll
be like jumping discord if you can't do
that i'm not playing with you i just
can't
i can't it's more it's more i bought the
xbox headset
to review it and for that reason of like
oh i can jump in
into discord at the same time as well
right for me the only thing that worries
me about it is
microsoft's track record with buying
things and then not supporting them
in the right way not talking about xbox
buying things and not supporting them in
the right way
talking about microsoft so we see what
happened with skype not that skype isn't
profitable and doesn't do well
but they just never added to it skype
should have eaten all these cats lunches
we should even know what the scene is
zoom shouldn't even we shouldn't even
know what that is simple ads
right skype should have evolved into
something
can i'm it's going to happen i truly
believe it's going to happen microsoft
money and they can do it i just i worry
a little bit about it
but i want it i do want it to happen yes
like that's fair enough fair enough
lord attic we had some brief discussions
earlier in the week when the news
first dropped now it's we're hearing
exclusive talks
with uh microsoft so maybe things are
progressive what are you thinking sir
i think that it's i think it's happening
i think
microsoft wants it for multiple things
uh i don't think this is a gaming
purchase i
i truly think that this is like one of
those things where they're looking at it
from
all perspective that gaming is part of
it but it's not the prime reason that
they're doing it
i think that because of this pandemic
they realized
that teams can go somewhere but teams
got a lot of issues so they need to fix
it before it can go somewhere
right i feel like in terms of gaming
prospect that you know they might merge
uh the voice chat of xbox with discord
i don't know if they go that far but i
think one of the key things that they're
going to do with with the game uh with
the gaming side is i think they're going
to merge game pass and discord together
i think um because that's where everyone
is they're in discord so where's the
perfect place buy discord and put
game pass in discord like you can't get
any better than that
it's just like right now uh you know
they got like eight different apps for
one's function
like they need to consolidate that to
one app does it all
and this core is the perfect app to do
it yeah nah hey make it
it's like i said i honestly think that
you know it's it's one of those
scenarios where you know 10 billion
seems like a lot for discord but it's
just like
they're looking at it was like okay you
know we're taking they can't take the pc
crowd seriously
unless they start making pc crowd moves
and they still haven't done that you
know people still don't like the
if game pass wasn't to where like you
know it
is on pc it's they don't get every game
first off
second off people don't like the store
third off you know
it glitches all the time sometimes it's
confusing what app to do what because
there's like four different apps for
xbox on pc
so it's like i said you could solid like
that all in the game pass you know
you know how it got got its little
server at the very top it'll say game
pass you click game pass it brings up
another thing and
and discord there's all the game pass
games and then you uh you could click
straighten that into the games and then
you know you could bring looking for
groups in the discord it it it's
it's the perfect marriage because
looking for cool fire
looking for groups would be
this is one of those scenarios where
microsoft won't spend this type of money
unless they have different avenues they
can take with it right like they
they don't it's like because they don't
want it just for gaming they don't want
it just for you know
the uh the the microsoft teams there is
literally endless possibilities they've
been trying to get discord for years
like and i think they got to the point
where like
10 billion man there's no way they could
say no to that go over there
phil tell them to take this 10 billion
and give me and write this paper
remember they they approached phil and
microsoft for my understanding
that's how i'm hearing this this was
them kind of evaluating themselves
and then possibly looking to sell and
reaching out to microsoft that's what
how the additional
work
that's what i feel like is going on i
feel like that i feel like one of the
key reasons they want to do it for
gaming is because the game pass like
that would be perfect having everything
everyone is in discord 24
7. the game passes in there you're
naturally like imagine if like the home
page of discord
is an advertisement for for game pass
you're gonna get
you're gonna get everyone in there be
like yo that game looks fun man like
because they're going to discord to talk
to their friends
right and they're going to get tripped
up by the advertisements that they're
going to be doing for game pass
yeah imagine also sorry let me just
imagine imagine imagine also with when
the when we're finally not downloading
games and we're just streaming them so
the google stager approach of like
they now have everything through discord
which i 100 agree with the tab at the
top
you click it you you click it once and
you play it there
yeah it would be very small one touch
yeah cloud integrate wow that would be
yeah that would be something solved
which what you got man i mean i i
i agree with you what addict said
makes a lot of sense because i think
that's why you have phil
in in those discussions where it's just
not other microsoft executives fill in
there
because i think a big part of it is that
the xbox is really microsoft's only sort
of
community like base thing right right
where
where where
the good thing solves let me just say
this real quick is look discord is used
for a lot of things is used for
podcasting
but let's be real 80 of what discord is
used for is games
to absolutely gamers to chat like if you
go on there and look
on all the servers almost all the big
servers is big youtubers and twitch
streamers
yeah and it is it just is that thing
where it's like
it makes sense that the conversations
happen
through sort of the the the lens of
gaming
but i think what alex said is true it's
a much bigger thing it's a microsoft
thing and the fixture said this as well
it's a microsoft thing
as opposed to a gaming thing because if
you think about it they don't have that
community where
you say i come to a microsoft product
for this right
you have you know you have uh google
with uh with youtube and then you have
like what else
uh you know facebook with instagram and
and and and what you
call it um amazon with twitch like they
don't facebook with instagram
we keep forgetting facebook's at social
networks
and that's the thing you forget about
that right because nobody talks about
facebook as
what it is now but what it owns um and
they need that and they need that and
like
like alex said the game pass thing is
essential to that because it is their
only sort of forward-facing
community based thing that is so
you can't look at game pass anymore and
really have an issue with what it's
doing right you attach
discord to that and then you integrate
that into
into the into the xbox ui and into into
everything that is xbox and microsoft
yeah
this is this see feels like a foregone
conclusion it's just a matter of time
the facts of the talks are now
exclusive that was big it advanced very
quickly
the rap it's the wrath to be honest with
you like you know
i want to point out that i'm not for
them like advertising everywhere on
discord you know what i'm saying like
but if you if i'm all for vote you
loading up discord
and the first thing you see is the game
pass out
the game pass page and then from there
you could go to your servers you can go
to everything
and like you kind of remember how like
you go to like netflix and it shows that
uh the uh the title is like
kind of transparent going left to right
in the back like
that's what they need to do because
people will see something oh that looks
interesting and they click it
they're done they they're already in
discord they're not going anywhere else
yeah it gets off and and as to the
worries about you know microsoft taking
it and and breaking it like
they've done with other things i think
they kind of learned their lesson
already about
taking these things just happened but
that's the thing
that was to me that is where they really
got like they tried to
compete to the king that's what i'm
trying to say and then
if you can't beat them you're buying
you're buying them because
it's like i agree with you yeah they
might be done building stuff from the
ground right because people
if they're not in the industry of that
industry as it is they're like
okay who's number one or two yeah buy
one of them or buy both of them
resources
trying to compete when you are
a dominant beast and you can just buy
them out right
you know so and control them i mean just
you know finish your points because
i just don't think i think the worries
are kind of unfounded i think they
realize that
and i that's why i think that you really
do have xbox
at at the helm of the negotiations yes
because again i think
what discord becomes within microsoft
moving forward
is sort of based on how it's applied to
game pass and how it's applied to the
xbox ecosystem
and plus you know the executives from
microsoft itself
they've probably never even really been
in rooms with the discord people
but like when you go to these events
discords they're heavy
and guess who's been in every one of
these phil's specialists
he's probably got a better relationship
with every he probably knows them all by
name and you go to like the main
executives at microsoft
some of them probably don't even know
what discord is well that's the
advantage of phil in the leadership
position you know and king is i know
he's going to go in on that too let's
get this super chat there i don't know
because um cool let me go from the
bottom up here uh max the lazy otaku
somebody buys evo microsoft oh you
forgot who i am
sony wow not buy evil they partnered
with them they only got 50 50 money they
don't got hundred percent money they got
money
oh my god they're going halfway i think
the reason
no they they could have bought them out
front they wouldn't wonder why i needed
them because they because they don't
want to write because they don't have it
they don't want to run it they want
someone else to run why why would you
rent it when you can own it so they went
in and they was like
what i get that happened it's the same
scenarios
been buying bethesda and keeping their
publishing arm and everything intact
they don't want to run bethesda they
just want to own bethesda that's a
different
it's kind of different though but you
get my point like they need someone to
run evo
they don't want to buy evo 100 because
they want so then you buy them and let
them be them
this is the difference where you have i
got half on this money
and i got all this money look regardless
what bethesda was doing because it was
in a way different ground than evil was
evo was going down right right right
not up not straight it was and that's
why they were
able to get they can buy things on the
cheap they go to the dollar store
wow bethesda might have have had some
hiccups
but why would you buy something like
evil and let everything continue exactly
like
the way it was there was that everything
was going downhill
who's running the ship right now all
right that's what it is
i think when you think about how evo was
running you remove all of the all of the
the sexual harassment stuff out of it
yeah the way evil runs per se is fine i
think
in that regard they're just going to
attach place the playstation name to
everything
and that's it i think in terms of how it
runs i mean if
it's it was fine i'm sure they'll make
changes but i don't think there was an
issue with that i don't think they to me
the issue right now is
how do we make it viable in a world
where people are still at home right
when when this this this this type of
gaming really requires you
to be in person right oh that's that's
the reason they bought them at this
pandemic wouldn't have happened
let's give
i got to be back on your show bro what's
up you missed you missed before dirty no
no no no no i'm going back
backwards oh salute yeah i was on this
podcast yeah
no no doubt thank you sir then we have
corey hale 20
chat my hoodie arrived and i've been
rocking it like boulders
shout out to the room another trip
podcast thus far thank you
thank you bro thank you uh then we have
dano five dollar super chat discord is
running on google cloud platform
microsoft has azure sony uses azure i
see cross-platform chat
parties between consoles and pc yeah
that's another thing i think microsoft
is you know they're not on that where
you know
they're excluding people so because the
last time i checked isn't xbox
uh party chat ran off skype
um i don't know i'm not sure let me get
brick
oh you'll be actually xbox well i'm
talking about the party chat just the
party chat i'm not sure
i'm not sure on the backbone let me get
brett bringing this is interesting brett
bingham with the 10 tala super chat
what's your take on who's buying take
two and devolver digital
saw on the sec site some documents from
both that suggests
acquisitions are coming mm-hmm or take
two
take two no everybody's talking about
take two but dividing i i can see people
may be looking at devolving take two is
huge
no there's very few people in this world
that could buy tickets
everybody has approved once the brother
split from the partnership
um that's when everything became about
that that is a point
you know that they might have split and
uh you know the remaining person just
that isn't that
is it viable to say that rockstar
probably has a pretty big say
yes
we got we got sage sony mama so broke
sony had to make a cheap repeat digital
ps5 just so they could afford a
pizzagate
you'll see big
he bought the classic t he had to get
the ip logo mad shirt hoodie to go with
the hat
my oldest son wanted a hoodie with the
crest after oh that's what's up
never use discord but how does it
compare to broadcasting on youtube
one of the feathers playstation has okay
okay yeah we have vogelskrieg yeah you
got that one just wanted to ask
so yeah that cog that's what i was
telling you about before that the the
crest one
seems to be like it just it comes and
goes all right
um let me make sure that i did nothing
we got roughness right here now that's
the latest on a second
lord of roughness with the five pound
super chat
xbox's strategy is firing the hot ticket
right now they got 2013 levers coming
back
they got devs queuing up discord could
see their future
high vibe set it up for lord king
microsoft in
discord now looks like exclusive talks
king what are we failing what's going on
exclusive because everyone else pulled
back that's when that's when you're
dating
and you walk in the building and you
know the broke boys got a cereal
oh who's that they told who's she
talking to you
king let's be real here it was one of
those things microsoft pulled up in the
building they walked in
everyone looked at each other and looked
at microsoft and said who invited
microsoft
while it was like i didn't know
it's a different thing when the
microsoft bling come in the room
shout out to oj it's baby jesus he
bought that premium hoodie
they looked like phil spitzer's here too
we're really screwed
so so all right so when you when you
lock into exclusive talks these
exclusive talks
it's uh this is when you're getting down
to the nitty-gritty this is when you're
handing over books and
you're trying to see what your finances
and stuff look like
all right let's put that to the side for
a second right i keep hearing people put
dirt on skype
now when i'm when microsoft's whole
vision and this was old vision the old
vision was when connect was in the box
connect was in the box and microsoft is
a service company
first and foremost microsoft is a
service software company
this is what they excel in this is what
they try to get into
they try to make magic money magic money
is giving you
something that you don't physically have
to manufacture and physically own
but it has a residual type of effect
with you that's magic money everybody
wants to get to
when they're asleep their money is
making money on top of money brand and
money
to turn into more money millions
talk a million this is
this is trillions talk here right so you
don't have to
manufacture any hardware you don't have
to do anything of that nature
what you want is your money making money
for you right without giving you a
physical product
that's magic money so when you had to
connect and they purchased skype
remember the whole thought pattern with
that was
skype was going to be run through your
connect that had all these wonderful
features inside
and your video chat was going to be
taken to the next level
skype died so i mean um uh um connect
died so did skype
that plan was it was faulty when you
thought about it but they still use the
tech behind skype
to bring you different things the tech
is still being used but it's not being
utilized to its fullest and that's what
y'all right at
right through so microsoft didn't
purchase the tech for detected
the tech is still working but it's not
working to where we
think it should be like
so but i also believe that these uh
they when the pandemic happened they
were in a unique position
where they were able to do skype with
their own tech
because they have the technology it's
theirs they lock behind this stuff
so they can work that way and i think
that's where they had the leg up
this discord right let's go everybody
knows me personally i don't know
i'm not a disco i'm
[Laughter]
and i'm in groups i have no idea and
then i was going on people's shows
and i had to be in discord so what
addict said is true
the pc base if you want to make pc moves
you have to be in the pc world facts pc
world
is a discord mc fix it just explain to
you
you have to be a very special friend of
mine for me to get into xbox chat
if not c in discord all right and that's
a pc mentality a lot of people
feel that way too continue he's not
moving off of that square that's his
square
yeah okay so now if you go in your choir
this you know how much better game pass
would do in discord like way better
this analyze the rub everybody thinks
it's not a micro
uh xbox deal this deal
microsoft eyebrows are raised by
game pass right game pass is a
service this is the dna magic money
magic money yeah you said that now
there's 400 million
users on discord 300 million
you know uh or probably dormant 100
million yeah there's an absurd amount of
active users that is active
it's probably the most highly used
service ever in history it's all about
community yeah
so 10 billion 10 10 10 10
billion dollars isn't a lot when you can
hit that demographic straight to the
vein yeah
100 it's like outsourcing like you
literally outsource the community
so once you're in now you can use this
tech
to enhance everything about you i think
this is the catalyst that takes game
pass
to a place nobody can touch i told you
this generation was over before it
started
this generation was over when they were
that they got no shot kick
no they haven't played
because right now you if you acquire
this situation
and they they do what attic says right
game pass is a click away the cloud is
inside game pass
you hit it and remember the great bill
still will
explain they want it to where it's
you click it yeah you're playing and
it's downloading in the background on
whatever device you're at
facts you're playing right off the rip
right so if google stadium saw this and
it's like oh
we're out of here
and they service was really good yeah
that service was good what about the
guys across the street that's borrowing
the service from you that can go half on
a certain level with you
they don't have a shot you know what's
crazy uh king
the fact that microsoft made google get
out of that it felt
like it's funny microsoft
is on life support on life support
what's funny is notice the people that
was capping for that service
for multiple reasons because it was
something new it was against xbox
uh x-class none other than talking
anymore yeah
my father's calling
listen i'm just saying this right
when this acquisition happened oh oh oh
fix it with the stadium
i had to go deep in my box
it's in the box with the rest of the
rubbish
he's right he's right a box of these
robots look let me say look
king started talking like that he's
gonna come for me and they just put
everything
into proportion for me like you're right
you just step back because you're right
you're 100 right it's just you know what
i'm going through
a business mentality listen guys
we sometimes we don't see the forest for
the trees yeah and that means
you don't see exactly what's happening
in front of you until it's too late in
fact i'm explaining to it i'm
listen i cap for microsoft yes
i had to listen to you playstation dudes
for a whole generation yep because of
johnny boy
because of donnie boy donnie boy screwed
us up terribly
shout out to them right man yeah shut up
there's a con there's a console for you
if you want to you don't want to do your
he damn passion he didn't have the
ability and the nuance and the
sophistication to move to a crowd
tv tv to get things to you in a problem
with maddie
tvtv and madden halo yes build up a tv
show
yeah yeah we got a tv show
so if they acquired this dudes listen
you thought that uphill battle was crazy
because we had about one
23 million now why does nobody keep
getting high on gay passing because it
goes up every day it's 18 continuously
it's the greatest service ever i see
people have to bend the knee to tell you
that it's the greatest servant ever
before when he was telling him
that it was detriment to the individual
is this description not going up every
day
it's going up don't encourage it was
added so i just i just
i just want to say this right
if you thought it was a problem at 23
what happens when it's 123.
off the rip y'all y'all sitting there
saying
he's cap this is your last console damn
this is it right here this is this is
you know why
y'all became a studio for a reason you
made sure
because you saw the writing on the wall
you was like oh because y'all got a
chance to get this or service y'all was
like
oh this is nice man that's why they did
it that's why somebody didn't deal with
it
yo we got internet internet i didn't
know that you had internet like this
across the world
oh my god that's when you take the
ghetto girl to the good
oh my god y'all having a good food
and she's like oh my god they bring it
what what's this water that you speak
that's what they said that's what sodium
oh
like if they buy discord and they
integrate uh and merge
xbox game pass into discord i i feel
like you're going to see like right now
like i would say a good 75 percent
of game passes on that is on console
mm-hmm if they buy discord
there might be more people subscribing
to game pass on pc than they would be on
console
like it's going to switch it's going to
switch it's going to switch overnight
and that's the crowd they want they want
that you know not to mention
maximus aurelia spencer doesn't want the
pc crowd
he wants the pc crowd more than anything
and not to mention
that like a lot of people will just
upgrade a game pass ultimate okay
it's on discord i want them on both so
you know
i feel like people underestimate it's
like i said about the evo
it's like look evo was made more from
from a playstation acquisition
i mean a sony one but they're definitely
going to use it in some way
in the gaming industry but discord is on
another level
this was another level i just disrespect
my kids they just keep putting their
self in a niche corner playstation keeps
but even if even when your ceo tells you
the console is a niche market right then
why would you go put yourself in a
deeper
niche corner with evil with the fighting
genre and i understand that's your dna
you know what you said again say it
again
it's something that you can easily
divorce yourself from right
there's something serious in the chat
all right what happened someone just
super chat while you guys blocked me for
supporting your channel that's messed up
i'm being blocked
you dude you're not blocked i i i don't
understand where that's coming from
like if there's like a serious issue
message me on twitter
but like to to my knowledge i'm looking
at you it does not
block yeah you're good continue it's
really misunderstanding what a timeout
or something means i don't know
anyway you got your balls because i want
to get in yeah no i'm i'm i'm done with
i just i just want you guys to know this
is where the rabbit
you know has jumped out the hole and is
running the show
right you're in trouble now but
it's okay you have a place here you're
going to be a a studio
listen on the 21st of of um of
april i will be purchasing mlb
the show yup i'm going to be supporting
this i
i feel that you know we have to support
our new developers
on a great new device please this guy
this guy's too much i can't do it you
see this guys
he's
christmas is gonna be a good time man
[Music]
give me a second no doubt no doubt and
remember y'all timeout is different from
yeah yeah i don't yeah that's the time
gerald mack
five dollars shout out to the lords
again another great show another great
guest thank you discord 10 billion just
in case you thought microsoft and xbox
are playing
and that's the thing people complain
about the price understand that you have
to
if you are going to make a purchase of
this size you have to overpay
yeah look at what happened with take two
they usually pay
what they would do and code master years
yeah let me look what happened with
minecraft
yeah you have to overpay if you're gonna
make this purchase but
after they purchase them minecraft
continue to grow
bro i thought minecraft was done when
they bought them because i thought
well we've tapped out this well and they
just kept going
roblox yeah yeah yeah yeah
roblox is not good vogel's creek just
wanted to ask okay i got that one
i got that one already right here we
have tim swope it's five dollars super
chat microsoft makes 60 billion a year
sony only makes
seven billion okay money talk and we got
sage five dollar super chat you guys see
that sony apply for a pvp loan from
small business administration
oh my god i got stopped
hey messi today bro this is what this is
what we've done this year
we got you in trouble i'm in trouble at
here
they're going to give me i'm going to
get an email like yo i swear you were a
fanboy but i'm not
as well i like it all i promise
these people in the industry they they
like they like to smoke
don't let them lie to you let's keep it
going let's keep it going man quickly
we got um raiden blade two thousand chat
rebuild and strategic xbox we
coming no doubt no doubt uh then we have
max delazio taku five dollars
i've been waiting for today so i can
hear king talk his talk about microsoft
fight discord
and playstation now going for one dollar
love to hear it
we're getting not that way we're getting
in trouble and we got spendy smith five
dollars
microsoft sorry sony we operate in
different circles you aren't used to
this this is boss move-ish
the book of acts of x2 damn
there we have flame 2 super chat discord
to microsoft why do i hear boss music
it's like it's like a demon soul's boss
like oh no
then we got jd gamer 5 super chat
prediction 150 to 250 million game pass
subs by the end of this generation
wow jesus versus 120 million playstation
5 sold so who wins
game pass baby the book effects wow
that's good that's crazy um raiden blade
two pound super chat
microsoft made another trillion dollar
comp company bend the knee yeah
yeah brother lee talked to him yeah one
bad this next one is cray
one bad mother five dollars stadium is
like weekend and bernie's
just call it stop pretending it's a lie
damn there's still a pulse man well then
there's no post they're just renting
stuff out now
just miming the uh the corpse of stadium
then we got max delazio taco once again
five dollars for chat
nintendo kicked sony out of japan and
now microsoft is about to kick sony out
of the us
they better set up headquarters in
europe there's a spot open just saying
earlier and then this is the one from
tim swope no my brother you were not
blocked yeah you were just top-down
brothers
yeah just time now but just yeah just
keep the personal attacks with each
other that's all we said it's good for
gaming guys
we appreciate the support though
absolutely then we have ever born soccer
two dollars from chat stadia is ivan
drago's status
remember he was dominant in the
beginning he can bleed
xbox will get game pass on steam so they
can get more of the triple a new
releases in pc game passes
[Music]
to be honest with you like i don't think
if they get discord and they merge
discord
into game pass i don't think they're
going to touch
yeah they're going to steam though i
think they still put games on stage i
think they still
no no i think they're going to put games
on stage but i don't think game pass is
going on
no it's definitely not it's the thoughts
i feel like if they got discord
they got where the people look people
might have
like you know the epic fanboys the steam
fanboys i'm team epic by the way just
saying that
but all of them are on discord yeah yeah
no yeah
you could sell it to
you ever notice the guy who has that one
good
chain yeah like he's good there but then
he goes and he over does it he has
then you see the next time he got three
four good chains yeah just be like man
you overdid it
microsoft going to overdo it
i think i think steve is just overdoing
it like we really want you want you
yes you know and and i think like like
adam keeps telling me and i really like
really everybody has a price
yeah everybody has a price but like gabe
has fu money just like they do
like i don't know but he's not a few
money but this dude got
had minecraft it was a very very
successful game
and they they they dropped that that
billion he's like
i'm out like i don't have to deal with
none of these people anymore i have to
deal with any of these customers anymore
i'm gonna go out bid jay-z for a mansion
i'm good
i think yeah at that point was having
some uh some issues that
he needed to separate from mike i think
i think the thing for me with the whole
steam stuff is
it just doesn't it doesn't make sense
for sting right right
and i get what i get what you guys are
saying like microsoft by steam
i see it right but like the whole like i
can see that cell
i can see that in my head that actually
happened and then boom they own it all
but
putting game pass on it just doesn't
make sense for them
to be honest with the microsoft store
terrible
terrible right how and compare it to
steam store
yeah okay i understand that but
microsoft store is fixable it is at some
point
how come they haven't fixed it because
they about to buy discord and put it on
there
but it will fix
it would have happened yet already and i
feel like the money that they're
investing into discord
they would just invest in this team
because let's be real discord's an
amazing
amazing sell but steve's a better one
for game time slow mo aspects
how does ea play make sense on steam ea
that's a different that's a whole
different kind of the fish because the
reason ea plays on steam
is because ea yanked all their games off
steam that i i can almost guarantee you
when that whole thing was happening with
epic store steam reached out to ea
i i don't think it was the other way
around i think they
reached to a good middle ground like
look we'll come back to steam
because epic is taking all your cookies
yeah it's like and what we'll do
if you let us put ea play on steam yeah
the only way the only way
uh game pass gets on the steam is it if
it's
a customer it's not the same thing oh
microsoft
exactly yes that if you're saying in
some way or form
then okay i can understand that but the
way it's set up right now
the game the way the reason ea works is
because you get old games you get old
games as well like
you get the 10 hour trial you get old
games you're not getting
you're looking outrageous right on steam
so you're gonna put on steam for sixty
dollars
or seventy dollars whatever it comes up
and then you can get it free in game
pass
it's just it just won't work they're not
going i see him the discord
the disco conversation we're having
makes sense the steamboat
only makes sense for one person which is
microsoft let me let me say this
hold on let me just adjust to this the
epic store
sony is tapped in with epic right and
they're making moves in the background
whatever playstation now turns into or
whatever the game pass situation turns
into i'm pretty sure that you're gonna
find it in the epic store
the epic store is a direct threat
to steam true that
whatever sony does is a direct threat
towards game pass
they're going to find some middle ground
they're going to work something out
and they're going to stomp out that
direct threat
we'll be back i'll be back to apologize
it goes back to it goes back to what i
said like when you think about the
logistics of doing that
it would only be sony games yeah yeah
you have to remove all third-party stuff
they're not having that third-party
stuff right yeah
give me your sony games at a reduced
price right whatever
eight dollar ten dollar a month thing on
epic game store and that would work
same way game pass would work on steam
if they just if it was
anything else just microsoft question is
the question is and phil knows this
right we're on the game pass side
the question is is their willingness to
do that right
yeah because you're breaking the brand
right time we got this
and we got to get out this topic and
this is not a steam topic and i get my
balls off
can't wait for it jesus all right let me
get these super challenges in coffee go
we got smitty spent five dollars so he
went to microsoft and said
they got breadsticks and everything in
silverware oh my goodness
and we have raiden blade two pound super
chat i'm telling you in june game passes
at 30 million
i actually believe that now
i believe that um brett bingham five
dollar super chat maybe gta 6 hasn't
been announced yet because it's an
exclusive
that is not happening uh it would it
would be a serious amount of money
yeah they're not doing it if anything
it'd be an
[Laughter]
microsoft isn't done buying stuff so uh
so it was xgs first then
bethesda then discord who's next sega in
wb is who i predict
and xbox will be king of fighters and
more king of fighters as well oh my
goodness
oh we got that what's next to go to be
the king of fighters fans
hold on we got damn we i got jumped in
exactly that's why we can't be doing
extra topics
okay we got lazy couch gamer five
dollars five something
uh fifa ultimate team and other services
alike are now rated 18 plus in germany
thought this could be interesting
greetings from germany big fan thank you
so much ladies couch gamer
braden blade two pound super chat
mondays another xbox announcement i'm
ready
oh okay exclusive okay okay we got
something coming in
then we have max the lazy otaku five
dollar super chat
calling it here microsoft and steam
versus epic games and sony
get console wars it's it's gaming world
war coming soon
yeah we talked about this a long time
ago that could happen too
um then we have lord roughness five
pounds super chat
xbox ain't playing dropping bags every
month it's like their competitors have
thrown in the towel from the corner and
microsoft are still punching
okay
look agree with all y'all you guys have
been on fire um the only thing i would
say i've seen a couple of detractors
you know and obviously what keeps
brought up is the skype thing that makes
a thing and i get it i'm saying we do
have to recognize
also a different era of microsoft this
is the sacha nadella
era you know what i'm saying where again
phil has a lot of control he's at the
seat for the first time this is not the
terry myers scenario
this is not the don magic error so that
is a big difference
also king and addict maybe said it
perfect about community
right microsoft for as big as they are
outside of xbox live
they don't have their own community
salute to you because you always got
good points but um yeah like the thing
is
they don't have it you know youtube is
synonymous with google
facebook instagram you know i'm saying
amazon got twitch
so the people that said yo they need to
build their own microsoft did try they
they tried with mixer you can't say they
didn't you know what i'm saying
so now it's like yo the best way like
king said outsource just get that
right in in your wheelhouse so the other
thing i keep seeing that annoys me is
like
i don't want them to get that they need
to buy studios this is not
mutually exclusive you can do two things
microsoft's money is long
you can do both of those things as far
as attic's point with the armpit
as far as points whatever and they do
them both
the mentality with it comes from a
limited mentality
when it's it's different when you got
unlimited resources
listen that's different at the end of
the day i completely agree and
i actually made a great point with
integration we
know the long-term play with them is
game pass right now if you think about
it as a tier maybe for nitro
or whatever it is this seamless
integration with this community
that's exciting and then the other thing
people are realizing this is also an
azure move
right because discord i believe sits on
um what you call it on google right you
take that away from your competitor
you put that on azure that's also money
on the back end
right so this that's a big thing and
remember somebody's on azure
right so this is this is big azure money
too that people
as far as brand long term so we got that
the other thing is that
if the mission is game pass right we
already said
because gamers got to get out their own
bubbles the mission is game pass and
game pass is the platform
right pc tv mobile
right you need a communication you know
you need something to to integrate
that's a great move that's part of their
overall vision
and then we already see they're
consolidating on the xbox network side
right
it's no longer xbox live xbox network
they're getting rid of the free to play
all this stuff in the multiplayer free
all this helps
an easy transition for discord you know
what i'm saying
yeah and um yeah provided no snags like
i
i really could could you imagine
this for you could you imagine discord
on a new switch
bro the the possibilities
is intense and here's the thing that
people don't realize with discord
that we go to the shows right and fix it
you go to the shows you go to you know
the events
you know when we meet with the
developers the number one thing is after
you get the information all that
hey go to this our game discord this way
the publishers the developers it's all
there like this is a community
that is literally interested in gaming
and you're just getting this
it's not a bigger community exactly that
is huge
so again i know gamers are like why why
why but you got to think
long term i think this is really
exciting you know what the possibility
is solve i'll let you go super chat
doing you gotta move on
like real quick you mentioned snags
right yeah microsoft has recently kind
of showed an inability to sort of read
the room a little bit especially when it
came to the
to the xbox live stuff or whatever which
they fixed quickly
my my only worry is that they integrate
this stuff
in a way money-wise right that looks
not great it's gonna just be here's the
thing this is where i feel where you're
going the reason why
i'm not worried in this particular
situation i looked at a situation like
linkedin and i looked at github
when they acquired those two right
linkedin still
operates independently like linkedin
like this the new microsoft now even
with the studio acquisitions
it's like yeah we got you but we're
letting you but there's the
still operate with your core culture and
values
yes there's gonna be some sort slight
integration but i don't
feel this imposing thing where it's like
we're gonna just rip apart the core of
who you are
now i think the new microsoft still
allows your identity to exist
you know what i'm saying and what kind
of makes you you so to speak so that
that's the only reason why i have
i get it you know i'm saying you're not
you're not wrong solved with the past
and
obviously they still have to prove that
the integration
will be seamless but like like attic
says there's
there's potential as far as like i said
the nitro and the game pass integration
i think
that is really key but again attic i
think
people have the right to be nervous if
they have the right because
like we just saw it with mixer this
isn't mixture this is discord this is
where
everyone are like at all times and
they're just worried they're like
if microsoft buys it is it is it ever
going to innervate because like you look
at
skype like this isn't something like
that could just be replaced
we're not going back to team chat we're
not going back
we're not going back to skype yeah
yeah yeah that's a shout out to slow mo
he said facts i'm getting info on games
from developers by saying go to my
discord
to get that info for marcus and stuff
mixed in there so look that's all i got
um before we do it because we i i at the
limit i know fixture had a hard time
guess what discord does
salute salute that's it all right cool
cool so let's move on man we got to get
these topics
moving and then i believe this is the
king man the kingdom
you got a little little combo action
though actually though this is uh
actually it is combo actually because it
is uh playstation 3
psp and vida digital storefronts all
closing you might as well do ps9 with
that too you want to do ps9 and combo i
mean
it's up to you just kidding we can slide
that picture
inside i have to be here to hear that
yeah you got it he's gonna be these
gonna be premium bars
and get a verse so look
let me just set it up for a bit i'll let
the kid go you know again you know the
reports are they were closed for good
this summer
won't be accessible from device anyway
again for the record digital storefronts
so report published monday said the
playstation store for sony's places 3
vita and psp
will be closed for good in july and
august making digital
copies of games for those platforms
unavailable
for purchase then on so yeah they said
ps3 and psp most likely the source says
will close july 2nd
vita storefront will close august 27th
and they said they reached out to sony
representative for additional
information no reply was made
at this time so it's king this was your
topic uh
what do you have to say sir some people
fears have come real
um you chose the platform and you went
in with good faith and you purchased and
you were supporting you support
you know shout out to the person that
has almost
all their games there and they they
support it through that uh
their storefronts digitally and i know a
lot of people that uh purchased
physicals said see i told you
see i told you see i told you um there's
the fears the fears are
being brought up now um i'm gonna give
you two takes i'm gonna give you the
joke take the joke tape
is got him
that's the joke that's the joke the joke
take on it is
you put your money in here yeah you have
fun playing it right it's done son
um but then i honestly think they're
going to use that to roll it into
something whatever playstation now turns
into
uh you have a wealth of ips and stuff
uh from uh vita from
uh the psp uh from playstation 3
but also you know keeping these
licensees and these games going
digitally
and read up and that cost the company
money
but it was looking to see where they can
trim the fat at on certain things
so maybe their own games come back in a
different revised
thing but to have a lot of those titles
there digitally and paying these
licenses
this stuff costs money right and it's
not revolving it's not it's not evolving
they continue
to lose cash in this one sector so when
you look at the structure of yps
uh now didn't do certain things this is
the reason why
you had too many tears that were losing
money inside that same thing and it
wasn't turning it
into what it needed to evolve into so
this is the natural progression of this
yes it's unfortunate for people
who purchased their digital games
through this platform
and was uh hoping that it would be there
for life it's not
but i think it comes back in a different
form but
sadly to say if you already purchased
these games that's good you already got
those digital games there
and i think you can still access those
games for
your as long as you have your id and
stuff hold on
it's funny rocker corey says sony we
believe in generations
i.e we taking stuff away from you unless
you buy all remasters
they did so except for your quote sony
we believe only in this generation
i just had to read those i was dying but
yeah that's that's the facts though
right
sorry no no no no no i'm not good i'm
i'm finished with it because
you don't want to this is a sore point
right
right because if you purchase this stuff
this is a very sore point because you
don't want to
uh be disrespectful for somebody's
dollar fast right
this is not jokes here this is you know
this this is this is
real facts here if somebody went and
brought in a whole catalog
of playstation 3 games and they paid
they didn't have anything
and they physically they believed in
this company for this
my only hope is whatever games that you
do have in your library
it stays open in a part that you're
still able to access
what you paid for yeah right now if they
close it down and they say well you no
longer can purchase
new content or you know what the
existing content here the store's closed
but if you're already purchased
good just safe right it's the only thing
i care about i don't care about if you
know if they close the store down it
happens
you know if it wasn't selling you close
the store this is what happens
but for those people that do have it
that like to go back and play they drake
yeah and nathan drake
they're uncharted or whatever they're
playing right those people should not be
excluded from the actual purchase
and i hope that is not the case so this
is a very sore point for so many people
and i know y'all guys
probably thought i was gonna rub it in
but i actually
feel for the sony consumer right that
believed in them and was giving them
their money
hoping that they would be around because
when you say you believe in generations
and you're killing generations off
that's uh that's fraudery that's a
legit lie you know so i i don't think
that
you know rubbing sultan a wound on
somebody that's actually hurting because
they only got a couple of months left
you know i don't i don't think that's
funny before i give it to you before i
get to fix it i gotta ask kicking this
what about
you know the idea well maybe because i
did hear this that like um
you know this is happening for some sort
of actual revamp on ps5 for those said
generations do you think
that's a possibility or you don't think
no i i hope it's a possibility
see we're going off of hope we're going
off of believing that they will do
something good for you
i'm telling you these and i want you to
see them
see the forest for the trees i keep
telling you if somebody keeps smacking
you in your face
don't think they're not going to smack
you again right so
we're at a point right now where you
have to keep
you have to vote with your wallet please
vote with your wallet you're seeing
something that you don't like
don't be mom about it don't be quiet
about it right speak up about it and be
vocal
you guys actually right now you have the
opportunity to fight back
this thing right here right now if you
make a big enough stink
i believe that they won't close it down
but if you go meekly and go quietly
and you take it it's gonna shut down on
that
and that's the thing we talk again
before i get to fix it like as far as
you know we can be a fan of a platform
we could be a fan of these great games
they're
making and stuff like that any it
doesn't matter we go at microsoft do we
get
when we get mad certain things that we
don't like and fix are you the same way
i know you're the same way
when yeah you know if we we're gamers if
we even if it's our company we like
if they're doing something we don't like
we got to call out so
again as gamers you know we have to be
careful
just because they made good games this
precludes them this excuses their
former pro policy or practice that we
don't like and this is a generation of
games like i don't want to get to me
like this hit this hit and when i get to
me but i have to ask you that
fiction let's get in because i know you
got love to stay well just just on the
fact of what you just said right it's
the fact of people have bought into
these ecosystems right
not everyone is as privileged as many of
us who own most consoles or own
everything because we cover it for our
hobby or our job or whatever it may be
and i think that's the part that hurt me
the most with this which is i'm not
bought into the ps3 ecosystem
but i bought a few games on vr and the
the king you hit on the point there
which was
we are living off prayers right now when
it comes to sony
and that is something i don't believe in
any company
there is no company i believe in like i
cover xbox for a job
doesn't mean that i like i believe in
everything that they say or they do
or things like that and that's they're
in a really horrible position right now
with playstation fans and
i'm a fan of playstation especially the
the games they produce but from a
service point of view now i'm like
hold up you can't just take that away
without reasoning
without having something you're going to
implement otherwise which is
okay cool if you're going to implement
this into playstation now
and that's your big grand plan you need
to tell us that now yeah because at the
end of the day
you're worrying me as a as someone who
i'm i'm in a privileged position where i
get sent
a lot of games i get centered most of my
games now so i don't buy them much
anymore
but for the normal person who doesn't do
this for a job right
they're paying 60 now going up to 70 and
you're sitting president for the fact of
oh we might just one day take this away
i understand this in your terms of
service
right but we're now hitting a point
where you're actually
acting upon your terms of service right
which worries me in a
huge way like it just does like
i see jim ryan's quote about like oh we
saw gran turismo and it was old and it
looked dumb or whatever i'm
definitely definitely paraphrasing not
word by word there
and i'm like okay but that's your
opinion don't put your opinion in
business
because if i want to go back and play
gran turismo one on the ps1 which me and
my granddad sat down and played
i have a memory of that i can still to
this day blow my cartridge and place
um streets of rage with my dad just have
the exact
same experience you don't get to tell me
what i like
i like what i like and then you get to
just sell it to me
simple ads that's my big thing to be
honest with you no
you know you hit something that was
rarely true
they're taking this away what are you
going to give
me right to replace what you're removing
exactly your father would take away a
console
and you had nothing he gave you
something replacing yo this will hold
you down yeah until i get you back
into a good evening i got
now this just one just really quickly
and i know you guys want to jump in
is this the water the reason why they
put their playstation now for a dollar
is this the reason why they put the
playstation now for a dollar because
you're devaluing your service anyway
so is it now worth a dollar is it this
this is where you insert dollar to try
to get people in the new people because
you're already wrong
the people that's already there right so
the new people that don't know what's
going to happen next
you know let's get the dollar in now
let's get it now it's like for a month
it's like for a weekend okay
and it starts as a weekend
it goes on longer because then microsoft
do it like for like a
promotional deal and then hey if you're
new you win for a buck
right so are you implying this is the
start of something i
i'm implying this is shady practice
we're removing this
the new guys don't know let's get them
in for a buck right now
so they can purchase whatever they see
in there they have some nostalgia
feelings
and it's over july 3rd
or whatever and the buck got him and i i
just
it's kind of shady the wrong timing the
wrong messaging
and i believe that they are microsoft
2013.
okay we're gonna see lauren that's bars
that's
bars right there that's awesome
what are you feeling about this uh the
digital storefronts ps3 psp
and vita did your stuff right away felt
like somebody should feel ashamed of
themselves like
i really do i felt like ps3 is a little
bit more understandable
because like and because they have at
least some form
a lot of those games i'm sure is on
playstation now right
they're probably trying to push them
towards that but it's just like
veda is the is the handheld it's not
like you're replacing that
right and it's just like i don't care
there's still people like laura collin
that's making games on it
right so it's just like you're shutting
something down with no
no alternative nothing to to to
replace it no no fixes you know i i get
it
you're saving money but it's just like
if anything like
let's say that you know they shut this
down five years from now
handheld just takes off to another level
they want to start up another vita or
something another handout
none of your customers are going to
gonna support you after that
like it's dead on arrival you never can
touch the the handheld industry ever
again
and it's just like you're loyal fans
because
because when they when i say veda fans
got fans
there's no more loyal than a vida fan oh
yeah beautiful
island baby
you know i love the final fantasy
tactics games and uh
you know the war of lions i can't
remember the exact name
right it's all there and it's just like
now i don't have a feed anymore i sold
that a long long long long time ago but
it's just like if i ever want to pick up
another vita
that's pretty much dead now that's the
point that's the point you've hit the
nail on the head i don't have my vita
anymore either but you know the fact of
the matter is
i could one day go buy a video and no my
my store is there
right now i don't have that in my head
that i know that the store is going to
be there
not the store be there but me even be
able to download the games already we
don't
know that information yes
what's crazy they didn't even really
give a lot of heads up yeah like i know
it's in august but this is room
but this is yeah yeah they haven't still
women
they officially made a statement but
they haven't came out and denounced it
right
[Music]
it get oils and it gets fungus fact this
is boils and fungus we have boils and
fungus stage
you're gonna need penicillin to get this
off i need this
like the beginning of the week and they
still only said nothing about it if this
wasn't happening they would have came
out
of that right or what they should do i
agree and it's just like
it's just like look like like i'm sorry
i got to be real i got to put on my king
hat real quick like
like it's not looking good for sony over
there like
and it's not necessarily in the terms of
we got a little thing over little thing
now they shutting down the playstation
3 store in the veda store right you know
their fans love the little one dollar
thing now that's there
right you know uh we heard nothing on
horizon zero dawn
we ain't heard nothing on god of war
which we all know that's not coming out
and it's just like it feels like it's
not getting any better in terms of that
like it just feels like the news is so
dry people are taking magnifying glass
to find no playstation content i mean
yeah
i hear where you going and what's crazy
is
they're getting news but it's not the
news the playstation
right right dude they'll figure out
video only thing i would say in fairness
clearly this feels like fairness oh god
it feels like there's something with you
know as far as sources that came out but
normally companies want to control the
message and maybe they have
a plan in place right but because this
news kind of got out early
they're not ready to disclose what the
eventual plan may be
for said storefronts or you know only
plan they got right now is finding that
mode that leaked at these codes
right clearly somebody somebody's
snitching
anyways they're kicking every door door
to the door
[Laughter]
so digital style friends where yeah i
mean you guys know how i feel about
maintaining legacy yes and and and
conservation and that's another thing
solved like they've contradicted
everything they've said from the
the gecko like you you you you highlight
backwards compatibility you shut down
everything else continue like it just
it's crazy
it's crazy to me if this is true because
um
you know the ps3 and the psp
especially with the psp go yeah were the
tip of the spear when it comes to
digital downloads obviously
with the 360 right 360. so they they
sold you on this idea a long time ago
right um again with the expectation like
fixture said that
you know and the fear that your stuff
should be there
whenever you want it but may not be
there right um
the fact that they haven't this is out
there and they haven't addressed it yet
is scary i don't know uh
has there it'll be any kind of like did
they talk about like downloads like if
you bought it are you good
if you don't know if you bought it
you're good you're good
yeah and this is what they confirm that
or do we is that what was said that's
the thing because
my question is because i'm because i
feel like if this is true
if you bought it you got to be good i
feel like that would open up lawsuit
right but what if you
bought it what if you bought it and it's
not downloaded are you good
that's my point that's that's why i'm
not going back to my i'm not gonna go
buy a vita that'll episode the golden
so i can like hold on to it like no
that's ridiculous hey fixer we we
we got a platform for you that's steam
no no listen
you good point about it this way too the
playstation 5 has
very limited space oh lord dude we don't
even know about that
don't don't let me know let me know let
me know let me know
if you have a ton of those games you're
trying to download it to your hard drive
so you can play it off your hard drive
what the hell is gonna happen and that's
that's not even a reality like
let's get into let's get into the
possibilities right
so they're going to open these doors no
no no i'm just going to talk about the
hard ones
um so what i hope that i i that i don't
know that if it's true
again considering jim ryan's stance who
knows um
one that all of this stuff is being
relocated to a
general playstation store where all of
that stuff will live
right hopes hopes and dreams that would
be fantastic
if you could connect your psp go to your
ps5 and download a game from
the general store that they have
bookstore it's right who knows
that's something i believe that could be
done they should think about that right
now
the other idea and it goes back to the
ps9 for a dollar right
from the very beginning i said place a
playstation is figuring out
what their version of game pass is right
and i always felt it's ps now that's why
shuhey is working on all these
indie games like they're investing more
and plus right now though but that's the
thing right i
everything that's been happening makes
you think well i picked the wrong
service they're based investing in ps
plus and ps now is going to go the way
the dodo
now the the thing is when you talk about
legacy content right
this is not the best solution but it is
the only one that is sort of available
to them because
because of the difficulty of the ps3
heart architecture
and it's difficult in that it's
difficult enough that they don't want to
do it right the cells
because it because it has been done it
is being done right now on the pc like
you can play playstation
3 games on the pc if you want oh
actually you can do it on your um
on your xbox series s and x right now
you can play
all your playstation right hey listen if
they kick you out we got you
are you gonna invest into the system
that you know for a fact
like as of right now it's a good good
possibility
yes four games are going to be up there
for a long time but it's just like
the way that they're moving who like
it's fickle like we don't know what's
gonna happen that's the thing when you
make moves that push
people to bootleg then you got a problem
you got a problem i mean look at the
three look at the 360 look at the 360
era right
look at the 360 era we're all guilty
right
what did they do for the xbox one era
right they did a lot of things wrong but
what they did right
was game share yes yes or when they got
back compat
into work and fight and work and and and
get all of our back catalog in there
you give people a reason not to cheat
you right yeah
and this is taking away all of those
reasons
for no reason because this is something
again we're speculating they haven't
commented it on us
i hope we're speculating in the wrong i
really do right if this is true
and those things are just gone and
remember it's not only about
the games that that you can get on
physically
there are a lot of those games that only
exist
that's the thing that's the thing yeah
that's the thing
what happens to that like you can't
this and this is what bothers me about
jim ryan's stance
this not caring about the legacy that
got you to where you are
[Music]
it pisses me off to no end it does
because
the people that are that are that are
that are soap boxing for your platform
now or the people that fell in love with
it
20 years ago but he wasn't there for
that
he wasn't different she never wasn't
funny
but you know the difference is i think
yeah is the fact of playstation
fans of 20 years ago i don't even know
where they are now
because this new generation of
playstation fans are
different they are very different
different like because i hate where at
the moment
because whenever i jump on twitter and
talk about video games it is just a
cesspool of
rowing and this is we're getting to the
point of like
this this news will come out that mute
feature got to be strong in you man
oh bro it's ridiculous i don't mute i
belong i need you to know that you're
annoyed
you're 100 right because the dude the
dude that jumped onto the playstation
bandwagon
in the ps4 era yes has no case that's my
point that doesn't care about ape escape
exactly you care about any of those
games that brought playstation players
and that's why they can do this and get
away with it that's why they look good
let me see let me be yeah let me see
real quick look what playstation
playstation's doing
in terms of like where they're they're
they're
rotating everything to the united states
like right
like pretty much united states is their
headquarters now like this isn't the
same place things let me let me ask
y'all a question the sake of fairness
i've seen some
uh conversations in the chat that you
know where's this
outrage when you can't play not all of
the og xbox catalog is playable
so they said where's this outrageous
what they've been saying they've been
saying
there's things that have uh licensing
issues right right
to communicate right they're telling us
what's going on one
two certain things don't run right when
you try to upgrade them they've said
that
they've said as much as well right so i
mean
if you're gonna have an outrage for one
game you can't access
right and you really want that game
timeout there's ways to do this
right there's ways to do this they're
talking about again speculation because
we don't know they're talking about
removing the entire storefront
the first first first of all
directly to your point yeah they're
talking about the back catalog is not
available
if it was never there you can't cry
about it right
we're talking about something that is
physically already
there i feel you i figured and they're
remote
a storefront is a different level
it's not like you're crying all day i
don't have this game of
available facts when are they going to
make this game right when are they going
to get it back
to your point technically this is three
digital storefronts
tells the history of playstation all of
it and then says
you can't go play in it don't worry
about it yeah like hey you got you got a
little jimmy saying
but what's that that's a vita it's this
it's dents
so so whatever whatever they say go buy
it down for it go away
y'all
you can download them later yeah video
games it still costs fifty dollars a pop
probably
it's not yo yo the market it's gonna be
crazy
yeah oh yo the people gonna be a
i look you want to go on amazon ebay and
just start yeah
i have a ton of these games all right i
don't i'm about to i i
okay so i brought my i brought my
playstation go
i have games that i i downloaded just
for that
you know because it was smaller it was
more portable i keep it on the move i
was never buying digital before then
but they there is only digital you know
machine and i had that for my psp games
there but then my vita i got all those
digital i really don't have i mean i
mean all those physical i really don't
have digital
when it comes to uh the vita games but
those individuals that are like me that
brought the psp goal
all those games that you purchase and
you and you have limited space
so you just like you choose which one
you're going to download and which one
you're going to put in
and i'll go back to the cloud and i'll
pull it down and i'll play it because i
got it
when i go to click in just like fixes
said and it's not
there am i going to be respected
right you know what what the hope is
that whatever if you made the digital
purchase already
again fixer's right we're assuming right
now they haven't
come out right the the assumption is
that you will still always
it's just like it's like when we do
microsoft when you don't
come out it like if this kind of leak
comes out a lot of the times if it's
completely
away from the actual thing going on with
microsoft they do come out and debunk
that
oh no this game is not going to be at
this event yeah
yeah aaron greenberg's good with that
this is this show expect this
experience yeah when you don't come out
and debunk stuff you cannot blame for
people to have assumptions
no absolutely and and and the thing is
if this turns out to be true right
what hope do we have for ps4
compatibility on a ps6
none zero i expect nothing i expect
nothing from sony if this comes out
there you go what happens
if it happens if it happens
yo if you just saw them cut bait
because it was too difficult when
they're being battered to death
right and game pass
they they have discord and they had 150
million
and everybody is having all this fun and
they just throw gabe's chain around a
neck for steam
just to floss what makes you
think a playstation 6 is coming anyway
we're going to become a developer and
put our games
we got to get moving yeah let's get
let's get to the last two
times all right listen all i'm gonna say
you guys you know made all the points
pretty much agree the only thing that
staff would do i'm a huge vita fan
huge video fan that definitely is sad
you know and like i said
it's on them now to come out with the
messaging to whatever the alternative is
going to be if there's an alternative
if there's not an alternative there will
be hell to pay
people are going to feel the way it
almost reminds me
of the smart delivery situation when
people were clowning
uh xbox at first say oh that's just
buzzwords and sony's doing the exact
same thing
and then we come to find out it's not
you know you're seeing
avengers you're seeing other things and
it's not
so there is something to gain
preservation and having a strategy and
an infrastructure
and like i said it's on them to get in
front of it that's all i got let's move
on
you don't cry now
anyway last one baby
you want to get these super chat oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah super chat so we'll
be checking with you i'm sorry
we got a few i apologize
[Music]
raiden blade two pounds super chat what
about ps4 battery dying and deleting
games oh my god
bingham five dollars so many fans sony
needs to replace jim ryan sony appoints
don matrix ceo
that would be amazing for me a lot of
playstations do you think he he's the
answer you know
what happened we got tone change then
rocker corey two dollars jim ryan
doesn't even game he has no psn account
yeah i mean that's crazy you be careful
for those dudes no there's my dad
shrewd businessman
[Laughter]
we have the rubber knob
sony be budgeting to save their pennies
for the next purchase who plays old
games
bushes be blooming then we have urban
ninja
five dollar super chat the fear is that
they bring this stuff back and make them
buy it again
guarantee some of that stuff they're
gonna make them true again yes
guaranteed they already did it with the
uncharted collection there's more coming
for you you're definitely buying the
stuff
sean jackson five dollar super chat sony
doesn't own the bandwidth or storage
capacity to keep hosting these games
they don't have larger server capacity
like microsoft google or amazon
that is true they should have thought
about that before they started selling
you digital games
fox well they started renting azure and
they [ __ ] the price i mean this is
this is to say
this is the same company that if your
stuff gets hacked and someone buys stuff
off
off their issues that they cause they
they
you go you do a chargeback on your bank
they ban your psn account so like
yeah uh then we have eagles fan 76 with
a five dollar super chat
you vote with your wallet i won't buy ps
now the dollar ps is following xbox lead
don't go 50
go 100 i want games day one like game
pass and then i'm in
i think i think that's a lot of people's
thoughts sat with your chess rubric
because that's the facts
super chat this is why i will always
refuse to support playstation okay
six layer 10 super chat and you know
which isn't worried about all this
hackers modders and private facts
they're about to eat they're about down
wait they validate that stuff because
that does more to protect your purchases
than sony does
shameful it is is true uh gaming forte
five dollar super chat i blame half of
iop for my sleep deprivation
hashtag sleep at work still had a great
time with the crew but my home incognito
is a wordsmith
that that's cap we talked for like an
hour and a half hour after the fight
but you could have easily shout out to
the whole
it's a crime that metal gear solid 4
isn't back combat arguably the greatest
playstation exclusive ever
but sony fans won't speak up about
that's true metal gear solid 4
is stranded yeah but you're going to get
that remix though relax you're still
coming yeah that is that that is pretty
much probably coming i'll take that
though still notice all right
to make sure there's nothing else part
of the problem i'm part of the problem
don't worry about it i'm there too yo
and try to try to buy
a playstation 3 fat right now with back
compat on crazy
i don't need 200 there you go that
didn't make
it's like 400 bucks that's crazy that's
cool i mean that's that's a good price
that's a good price on that old tech
it's a i thought that was probably one
of the best playstation threes
foreman grill the first one
yeah that would be very nice one more
super chat andy crawley with the twenty
dollar
chat hi lords lord crawley in the house
bought the last
episodes at work i think i should wear
depends oh my you guys deserve a raise
laughing and carrying on
i appreciate you brother go go go to the
bathroom search yes don't do that please
please no no no release on yourself
just move please at the iron lords
let's just do id at xbox real quick so
let's talk first quickly about
just very quickly about the cadence of
this and
it was not good i hate it hate
hate is not a strong word
oh okay okay yeah steven shout out to
blind gamer steven who didn't want the
interviews
during this this is the conclusion you
get when you put twitch streamers to
host things
number one because twitch streamers and
hosts are two different things
trust me i'm good at both hire me
bars who wants a 15-minute interview in
something
it's just it doesn't work you can't have
a three-hour show you can't it doesn't
work
it doesn't work that was that was bad
that was bad uh later on they released a
montage video that was like two minutes
long that king tweeted it it said this
and this is exactly what they needed to
be amazing you show us
those little snippets and then you talk
about specific games in detail
afterwards
yes and that's it yes so that that was
not great
i've been told on the internet we're not
allowed to complain we should have known
that it was just indie games but you
it's nobody's complaining about the
indie games nobody's complaining about
the in the game
this is this is the presentation
thank you i mean games was fun
i enjoyed the game portion that's right
so who was in there arguing
after they said a million times this is
an id at xbox presentation no no no
no one's arg what i'm seeing on twitter
for some
is they're not they're saying that that
we shouldn't be upset
about you know what happened because we
knew
it was going to be indie games and as
opposed to
the issue is format versus the games
themselves i think
we're all in agreement here i think it
would speak for everyone for once
that the games are not the issues
but again you are allowed to criticize
format presentation that's what we said
and i think there's this separation i
even see some comments
what's wrong with you lord but you know
someone i'm unsubscribing
because you guys got mad and i'm like
bro
yeah we're not we're not david but the
whole thing of matter is again
it's a difference between the games
being shown how you show them and
presentation that that's and
and the problem is that when you're
doing live reactions right
and you've been sitting there half hour
through an interview facts and then they
show a game
like your your emotional response in the
moment might be less exciting
right than than it would have been if
they would have showed you that game
right 45 minutes before that and they
didn't tell anybody it was gonna be four
hours but continue continuing
exactly so that's it in terms of that
that was not great
just i i love to hear the devs talk
right yeah give me a two minute dev
quick interview and i'm talking about
their game two minutes after you showed
me the game
fantastic everything else didn't need to
be there love chris charla
yeah um we know what chris charles job
is
if you know what he does so that was
unnecessary so that's the
that's what bugs me though by asking
they ask like oh how'd you get games on
idea xbox like devs know this so why are
you
the audience doesn't need to know that
that doesn't need to know there's lots
of lots of little things that just
didn't need to be that i totally agree
with you
exactly 100 so what i want to hear from
everyone is what were your favorites
coming out of the show no
no doubt i'm going to i'm going to yeah
fix it definitely dsn ascent
it looked dope like it looked dark i was
i was like excited for it beforehand but
like seeing that gameplay that they did
which again this is what these are for
to get us hyped for these type of games
that we wouldn't see on the e3 stage
right
that game looks amazing to me that was
my favorite game of the show
that's what's up that's what's up lord
addict those uh id and xbox man
i think that the pacing was horrible
i think that look
for for the type of way they did it i
don't even think
it was the issue i think the issue was
the lack of new
i felt gameplay some of the people that
were hosting some of the talent that
they chose to do it didn't know what
they were talking about you can tell
they've never played even
remotely in that genre of the type of
games i felt like that was an issue
i felt like they should have been some
form of thing at the beginning showing
what all the games are and then
afterwards you go into that way people
just want to see the games
you get them out of there they're out of
there and then you get the interview
i feel like the interviews could have
been exactly how they work right but
after actually yeah yeah i agree i felt
like
the interviews with the devs was
meaningless a lot of the time because it
felt like it wasn't about the game it
was about like an experience with the
game
right uh and that would extend it like
they spent like
10 minutes talking about like a cooking
simulator got nothing against the cookie
simulator
but a lot of that had nothing to do with
the game yep
right and you know i i
think that this needs to be restructured
yeah
but like part of me look i'm i'm not
going to go into
i just hold microsoft i'm not going to
go into them
this was a twitch thing because well my
id at xbox was uh
the brand yeah and they lend their brand
over to twitch and allow twitch to run
so they're so clear they're quick and
act king
you're making a good problem give it
back you got it so the question is if we
we putting the responsibility on this as
a twitch event
then the question becomes then why did
microsoft
entrust twitch to i don't believe there
was any microsoft oversight
i think i don't know i don't i don't
believe but it's their product though
it's their games it's it's their
announcement okay
regard if there was no oversight it's
even worse that means they didn't care
yes honestly but i think they gave him
the format i think they told him exactly
what was going to happen so
whoever said yes i told you before when
was watching whoever said yes to this
was wrong
right right um it's a different way you
presented they put the montage out and
then they said
that we going to go into deep dive if
you they put the montage out
you saw these games these are the games
that we're going to highlight at this
point in time
and we're going to talk to the
developers right and then just
look around and watch yeah it's is like
i get it like okay
it's like i was saying like i'm not
gonna go to too much because
i can't hate on twitch for promoting
their brand that's what they're supposed
to do
right yeah but they're not gonna do it
and i get that but you'll net like the
reason that i let this go a little bit
is because
i'm all about giving content creators
getting shots
if you notice when you look at it there
wasn't the pokey tears in there there
wasn't the corpses the cycunos
it was mid-tier to smaller twitch
channels to bring them up and
the the issue that i had with it is i
felt like they chose some of the wrong
people to put on there mm-hmm
it felt like kind of like like oh i like
that like someone at twitch that was
handling this is like
i like that chick she's the host like if
they didn't really
want to bring they didn't want to bring
that up addict and i i just listen i'm
not going to waste 10 minutes on this
because that was four hours
so i'm this is not going to get this is
not going to be a long segment at all
the games that i like was wet my beak
too it's stockholm
it's not
[Music]
the murderous penguin y'all call it a
crow penguins
walk crows fly oh this was a walking
crow
oxymoron shout out to the death star
down with the penguin that was a good
book
i thought that game showed so much
promise yeah and it was so polished also
the the dudes that did guacamelee
yes and guacamelee uh that that game
that game was a
that i think that game is finished i
think they're just you know
uh working out when they're gonna
release it and stuff like that and
timing a date
that game also uh looked polished and
good
there was gems there yeah for sure
about games yeah so release the montage
tell give
to tell people four hours you gotta get
this expectation continue you know but i
mean it kind of felt like
like i know they probably had time to do
this but it didn't feel like it was
planned or
really right like yeah it felt like
because they didn't even tell us it was
four hours long
if i would have seen it was four hours
long we never would have straight
i tried it i was like bro yeah
i only played resident evil i was like
nope like five hours before
they knew they said it was foreign yes
yes yes it's just like at that time
people's already committed committed to
it yeah yeah
how do you keep an idiot in suspense
that's exactly how i felt
shout out to the realm for rocco with us
they came and they stayed and they
rocked
you but i will i say to this point king
that if i see the twitch name associated
again
with an idiot xbox ah sorry realm there
won't be a stream
it will not and i'll jump in real quick
cause last the last year they did it
it was dope it was charla they just had
video of the game
with the developer talking in the
background yeah you know what i'm saying
so it's like i was like yo they
should've went with that but again
neither here nor there they gotta they
gotta fix that the format the pace as
far as the games
exo mecca dinobots battle royale
silva don't kick don't like the civil
but it's all silver baby we got silver
too much get your next generation
feature and you're gonna oh if i use it
yo exo making look amazing i was proud
to see that yo i want to shout out a
couple of people um
we got a shout out oh boy ariel knight
forgetting
on the big stage that was cool we had
him in the realm
content you know saying developer of
color the brothers got his game out
there
that's one i think that's one of the the
things that like i kind of just
let the whole thing go like i don't i
didn't like it but to me
this was this wasn't about the people
watching this was about
highlighting the people making the games
highlighting the stream is interviewing
the game
i just felt like there was a better way
and better people today oh yeah
they actually knew what they were
talking about if you would have had
that okay okay okay if you would have
peter
that i don't know what was going on
that know that genre that know how those
games operate that
actually ask questions that are good i
felt like we would we have a completely
different topic and save that for the
end of the show
so like i was saying my thing was
on black like i said another yield joint
12 minutes look cool i just wish we
got a new trailer with that um stalker
two looked good
just wish we got a new trailer with that
but i am happy it was there
we had i've been saying the new trailer
thing a lot a lot among us was a huge
gay
that was a huge gay on the joint you
know what i'm saying shout out to what
is it lost eledon's what does it eat
elderly the the fire emblem clone that
got black people
i was very happy i said the clown the
chat was clowning me black people in
fact
i was happy no let's go inclusion
we had stout and people of color in
a medieval kind of game fat now king
remember the joint that was calling in
i was calling it the pillage game that
looked like oh chivalry two
chivalry two sons i was itching to me
but what about the god of war 2d god of
war yes yes yes that's
oh so song of iron of iron
the end of the day regardless how we
feel about it yeah let's be real here
the real winner of this was i was it was
game pass
full facts like the best games at this
event are coming again
to complain to to complain last point is
to king's point
you know a lot of those games they after
the fact we found out like 22 of those
games are going to be in game pass right
yeah they weren't
they were like we just needed more you
know that that's a highlight that's a
moment production
yeah you gotta highlight that you gotta
let the audience know yo
these are gonna be a game pass day and
date
and that's not hard to do so again the
mark was missed there you know what i'm
saying
and it's a shame for experts i'm hoping
after this maybe a lesson
is learned maybe you need to control
your own event and
and and do this yourself because yeah
that goes to the thing it's like
it felt like none of these people played
xbox so none of them even remotely
think thought about asking is this
coming to game pads
yeah last one i say rush that's a double
big get that's another good yeah
you guys are gonna play rust um i play
rocks on youtube yeah so if you guys get
into
us yeah facts we gotta go
real quick let me just give mine uh one
that you guys did not mention is that
side scrolling jrpg astria ascending
oh yeah oh my goodness
it's made by like x final fantasy games
of final fantasy it's bad final fantasy
devs behind it you're going crazy for
that
one girl yeah one sick dagger so uh
so that um song of iron i love that
brother and then and then um there's
another one that came out
like on the 26th i think it's lost oasis
it's out already something like this one
game that's out already that we
i have to try that out today um and then
like like
like fixer said like the ascent yeah
when you look at a game like a 3d
isometric game with that
particle effects the lighting yo when
that is a next-gen game yeah that's the
perfect game that i talk about that when
you see it and when you look at the
perspective you're like this is not a
next-gen game this is not showing what
this machine could do
look at what that game is really doing
um that game is the next gen game
no doubt that game is bonkers
yeah so we all we all got our balls off
we good good we got to come good
man hold on i got a few super chats real
quick okay go on a second
uh michael aka bestseller's finest five
dollars in chat sad part is
as if playstation fails it's over this
is the only true money maker
i told you that like king said it's over
god bless say less
and yes let's keep it xbox don't
encourage yourself
like that daniel ngo not gonna lie i
dreamt about that soup still boiling
oh that soup
should have known playstation was in
trouble when that ps5 design was
revealed
wow then we uh
when the dude had to break it down then
we have to say two for ten dollars do we
chat
it has just been brought to the
attention of the realm by laura cognos
there has been treason
this cannot stand heads must be locked
off who dared suggest
unsubscribing got we got threatened and
unsubscribed because we were mad at the
format
okay then we got raiden blade two pound
super chat death store all the way crow
then we have yes then we have dt
taylor five dollar chat well they had
good eye candy
oh what behave yourself
um what else did we get anymore i think
we all right we are good
paul we're good yeah we're good all
right paul let's out
this question all right the new iop poll
will be um or it should be up on loads
of gaming.net gonna check that out
to the question with reported exclusive
talks of microsoft acquiring discord
how do you think microsoft should handle
integration
if the deal is finalized the choices are
eight
complete integration with xbox network
and azure cloud
single unified network between pc
console mobile etc
b make discord run independently
merge community slowly through optional
nitro and game pass
tears or c i don't care i still feel a
way about skyping mixer flopping
[Laughter]
those other choices please rock the ilp
vote when it goes up black ronin welcome
to the rum throw the crust up but more
importantly
for damn near three hours lord mc
fixer the bed of the hour rocking with
us
a legend man an absolute pleasure to
have you to finally do this brother it
was so much fun we wanted to talk to you
for hours upon hours man where can i
find people find you
what you got going on yeah the big thing
i'm pushing right now is my main youtube
channel youtube.commcfixar we're very
very close to hitting 5000 subscribers
so i'd love it
yeah let's get them near you could help
get there that would be
amazing if you're into live content
twitch.tv
fixer and again like i said if you're
into xbox content king i'll be there
soon
[Music]
the rum gotta go there and show uh m.c
fixture how we roll man
hit that sub button amazing content yo
talk about grind perseverance
you know just one of the good guys in
the community man and we got to
celebrate the good stuff so
please people you know realm send some
love over to his channel
support what he's doing you know what
i'm saying we really appreciate it man i
mean it makes a lot means a lot to us
but yeah again brother your story and
again it was i'm glad we finally got
this done yeah this is this
that's what i'm talking about chad put
it up for him you already know lord
attic man where can i find people find
you what you got going on sir
oh you can follow me on twitter at lord
addict iop mm-hmm
one thing you know definitely want to
remind uh the realm uh
cool in there watch that uh you know it
takes two string with me and king i'm
assuming that's going to be
some entertainment you know appreciate
uh m.c fixture for coming on the show
man
it was a great uh great podcast
definitely like
i encourage all of you man go on there
and subscribe to this man on
youtube like you know sometimes it's
just the little things that seeing that
subscriber count go up
a couple of 20 30 to 100. that will make
people's days quicker than anything else
you can know
the dude came in here he he gave us more
time than he needed
to yeah i don't know what's going to
happen
that's love though that's lovely i
appreciate it thank you mom for real you
already know
lord solve what can you find people find
you what you got going on
you know you can find me on twitter lord
top iop bx sovereign on psn and xbox
live
um we got one more super chats room
kingdom two dollars for chat
2027 ps6 brought to you by xbox game
pack oh my god
and of course your big shout out to
fixer fixing the moment i saw you on ign
i was in brother i was in a hundred
percent
uh love your content love love the
passion that you bring to it
and just the honesty and just i love
when you lit when you hear somebody and
you see somebody and you know that is
them
it's not a show it's not it that is them
and absolutely amazing i i love your
journey man and much success to you
thank you for joining thank you man
real quick before i forgot oh gee it's
baby jesus
bought a premium pullover hoodie he said
i needed that long dead iop drip salute
to you i didn't want to miss you
you bought that live and i missed that
we had to get that oj baby jesus
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
week someone um someone put in the chat
i ain't waiting i ain't watching a
four-hour movie
awesome me i'm watching uh sure can free
suggest
facts um i want to take the time out to
respect the time
facts and and and history of our
uh beloved guest and i say beloved
guests because brother
you said some stuff with that i think
it's a first
problem okay i wanted to do a deep dive
with that
unique
you're gonna chop it up yes okay chop it
up
oh but mc fixer big salute man bigger
thank you for sure
everything that you do is fantastic i
mean there's a lot of heart
behind it uh and and getting to know the
person
and the reason why the motivation-wise
you're selfless and you sitting here
four hours with us
you know talking video games you know
having a great time there's also showing
you how selfless
you are as a human being so it was
nothing to me to go subscribe
and follow and and find you on twitter
and follow and i and
everybody that is still watching please
go out and do the same thing you show
respect for us go show respect for our
guests
and my xbox and then he got another
channel to my xbox and me podcast y'all
you got two checks
okay
um but thank you for giving him a rich
history and texture to to your life and
a peek in
into your life thank you so much
appreciate it uh everybody uh
again tweet this out or uh
re-uh share it to everybody let
everybody know
it helps with the algorithms yes like i
keep telling you
it's coming out of recorded it i haven't
sat down and done my part because i'm
doing so many different things
and uh me and sovereign this week is uh
doing the road map
for iop going forward so we're going to
sit down we're going to chop it up
we have a lot of exciting things uh
coming forward
if you want to see some of that exciting
stuff go watch dolph castle x
last uh friday where i conducted an
interview
with uh you the ubisoft uh
nice uh designer at ubisoft he designed
the swag the toys and he's also doing
his own
statues right now with house of god so
uh
if you want to get a peek into my brain
uh go watch that episode on uh dcx open
mic
at 9 p.m on fridays and you can check
that stuff out absolutely man again
realm thank y'all man shout out to corey
hell 10 super chat thanks for another
monumental show iop
hashtag mlp the show with gamepad you
know you know something i don't know
because i'll wait i won't pre-order
jim ryan ain't having that one no i
don't think jeffrey will put that again
fast
you know if it's in game pass oh lord oh
you might as well
[Laughter]
don't say don't put that on me i
definitely wanted to give a special
shout out back
shout out to kid smooth for selling me
his playstation oh my god
a thousand plus dollars absolutely oh
get dutch get done let me get done
yeah yeah that's the homie one of those
who's gonna make it big five pound super
chat [ __ ] after booze one on one and add
song of iron with joe
he'll also be doing an in-depth chat on
the midway mix-up on
with cj grant your salute because dutch
that's that's the living viking
you know what i'm saying neverland's in
the house stand up and he's going to
have that devil so if you like song of
iron at the indie show
go check out boom go check out wonder
and dutch's channel midweek mix up
they're gonna have
that developer on so salute to y'all
that's a good game anyway look man
fantastic show fixer brother you know
you're welcome be coming back you
already know what it is
good to see you grinding love this story
look y'all we're gonna have a lot of fun
stuff planned stay tuned
the next couple of weeks are gonna be
the next couple of two months gonna be
fire trust me we got some stay tuned we
got heat
look thank y'all for rocking this was
fun man everybody enjoy your sunday so
if you got anything else before we go we
got we got nothing to say yet
right nothing to say yet okay because we
wanted there but once
once it's officially confirmed check the
iop twitters the social medias on that
we're gonna put it out there
hopefully y'all like what we're doing
like i'm not gonna say anything but
be very like you got to pay attention
on our twitter because we might be
changing how things normally go
next week so i want you guys to be
prepared very very
parents very observant on that
do me a favor uh one of the mods like
spam our twitter in the chat like
because we might not be next sunday i
don't know
what's going on yet yeah if we change i
want you guys to be aware that we might
not be next sunday
no doubt yo hold up we got jesus christ
in the room okay i gotta say jesus
christ
[Laughter]
yo when i say that my wife turns around
i was like why using the lord's name in
vain
like that's his thing shout out the lord
jesus
christ lord jesus christ salute florence
mr show taking care of him
congratulations but i'm excited to watch
it later
in the round no doubt it's always good
he got a big he got a baby
you got a baby
next week stay tuned podcasts get
optimized for the series
listen we gotta go everybody enjoy your
sunday we out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
to